Moin Leute, Twitch Space, danke für den Sub!
Oh, ich muss mein Headset noch umstöpseln, sehe ich gerade.
Kurz mal ne Runde Headbanging.
Hörst du sowas privat? Ja.
Jetzt nicht unbedingt exakt das, aber sowas in der Richtung.
Also das auch, aber...
Leider kann ich euch nix
im Stream spielen, weil es doof ist,
dass sich Twitch so entwickelt hat.
Jetzt könnten wir jetzt die
Wikinger anschmeißen.
Moin.
Zum Einschlafen, du wirst lachen, man kann bei sowas
tatsächlich ganz gut pennen. Ich meine, man darf das nicht
mega laut machen.
Also, du kannst das jetzt nicht so, dass du, ne, aber
so, so, das ist gar nicht schlecht, wenn sowas
so als Hintergrundrauschen läuft. Ich finde, das geht voll klar.
Was sind meine Lieblingskopfhörer?
Ganz ehrlich? Mein MMX 300, was im Endeffekt
auch nur nen
Vibe Dynamics...
Ich glaub, was ist denn da drunter?
Was ist unter dem MMX 300 drunter?
MMX 300 drunter, ähm...
Den DT 770 oder sowas, glaub ich. Weiß jetzt gar nicht genau.
Das ist sicherlich nicht der geilste Kopfhörer. Ich hab tatsächlich noch
deutlich, deutlich mehr hier hinten hängen, die ich aber so gut wie nicht benutze.
Weil ich es einfach zu anstrengend finde und mehrere Kopfhörer zu haben.
Linkin Park, Linkin Park geht auch.
Ist jetzt aber nicht unbedingt so mein...
Meine Lieblingsband.
Ähm, wusstet ihr, dass Linkin Park, glaub ich, die erfolgreichste...
Ich will nicht sagen Metalband, aber
die erfolgreichste so in Richtung
Metalband ist der jüngeren Geschichte. Die haben übelst viel verkauft.
Linkin Park sind...
Die waren richtig fett im Büsnitz.
Baumhausstock, Pog, Subscription, dankeschön.
Okay.
Hat genug, hat gebangt.
Übrigens, das Game, ich hab mir das gekauft, zu Release, nie gespielt.
Ja, deswegen, ich weiß gar nicht, ob die vorhaben, noch irgendwas zu machen.
Das letzte, was man von Linkin Park gehört hat, ist,
dass die irgendwelches altes, unveröffentlichtes
Zeug nochmal irgendwie ein bisschen
raushauen wollen. Aber ansonsten, glaub ich,
weiß nicht, ob da je wieder was kommt.
Und eigentlich Wave machen.
Aber Linkin Park war zur damaligen Zeit schon nice.
Das war ja, sag mal, so um 2000 noch etwas rum.
Da hab ich das auch relativ viel gehört.
Die hatten ja quasi so ein, zwei Alben, die richtig durch die Decke gegangen sind damals.
Was auch, sag mal, die ganzen Jugendlichen und ein bisschen, ein bisschen
kurz danach rauf und runter gehört haben.
Wobei, was ich ungefähr zur Zeit
rauf und runter gehört hab, damals als Linkin Park
angesagt war, war nicht unbedingt Linkin Park, sondern
Evanescence.
Und es gab, also ich hatte nie irgendwie großartig
so einen, wie nennt man das? So einen, so einen
Komi-Crush oder sowas, wie man das nennt.
Ja, also dass manche Leute, die gehen ja voll ab
auf irgendwelche Boybands oder so und fallen dann in Ohnmacht,
wenn er in ihre Richtung guckt und sowas, hatte ich nie.
Die einzige, die ich wirklich sehr, sehr nice fande,
war Amy Lee von Evanescence.
Da,
da hab ich gefanboyt.
Weil die ist jetzt auch alt. Die ist, glaub ich, ziemlich, ziemlich genauso alt
wie ich. Ich glaub, eins, zwei Jahre älter.
Wie alt wollen wir mal gucken?
Wie alt ist Amy Lee?
Amy Lee ist, ja okay, die ist drei Jahre älter als ich.
Sieht aber immer noch nicht schlecht aus.
Für 42 oder 43.
Zurecht, ja. Die war nice damals.
Aber ansonsten hat mich das nie sonderlich interessiert.
Muss man seinem Kump leider sagen, dass man sich intern
woanders beworben hat? Am Ende sieht das so aus, also müssen musst du
wahrscheinlich erstmal gar nichts. Er wird es früher oder später mitbekommen.
Und ich weiß nicht, in deiner Situation, was taktisch geschickter ist.
Das an die große Glocke hängen oder nicht.
Also wenn er dir auf den Sack geht, wenn er mit der Gruppe ist,
oder deine Gruppe so mit der Gruppe ist, dass du sagst, alter gehen die mir alle auf den Sack
und ich hab schon 500 Mal was gesagt und jetzt hab ich mich woanders beworben,
da würde ich möglichst viel Zeit verstreichen lassen, bis ich das offiziell bekannt gebe.
Oder bis er es mitkriegt,
dass sie dir einfach weniger auf den Sack gehen können.
Ansonsten, keine Ahnung. Das kann man jetzt wirklich so pauschal nicht sagen.
Das hängt wahrscheinlich ganz von der Situation ab.
JVO mochte ich noch nie.
Da hab ich die Faszination nicht dran verstanden.
Das war damals bei uns natürlich total angesagt, zu Zeiten,
wo ich noch ab und zu mal was gesoffen hab.
Mit Leuten aus der Schule oder ein bisschen später.
Mittlerweile, ihr wisst ja, ich trinke nahezu gar nichts mehr.
Nichts. Also ich vertrag auch nichts.
Wenn ich irgendwie mal, das ist so schlimm bei mir,
wenn ich zu, sagen wir mal, zu Silvester oder so mal irgendwie so ein halbes Glas Sekt trinke,
merke ich das gleich. Instant.
Ich bin das absolut nichts, null, gar nichts mehr gewöhnt.
Und zu den Zeiten war das halt super Saufmusik.
Wobei ich ehrlich sagen muss, ich hab die Faszination davon nie verstanden.
Mir hat es auch nie gut gefallen.
Gab sicherlich noch ein paar andere Bands, wo ich die Faszination nicht verstanden hab, aber
Ja, also JVO ist tatsächlich so eines der Dinger.
Keine Ahnung.
Boah.
Alter.
Ja, ist ja gut.
Mach ich jetzt meine Mappe.
Boah.
Riesen Krach wieder hier.
Tokio.
Ja gut.
Das hab ich.
Okay.
Das konnte ich eh nicht nachvollziehen.
Da war ich aber schon zu alt damals.
Ja.
Da war ich schon zu alt.
Aber ein paar Sachen, muss ich sagen,
Ich bin ja eigentlich schon seit jeher so der Anti-Mainstream-Typ.
Also ich mag Sachen, sobald sie Mainstream sind, nicht mehr.
Irgendwie merkwürdig.
Auch wenn ich es vorher gemacht habe.
Was auch immer.
Aber
So ein paar Sachen
War
War gar nicht so kacke.
Also ganz im Ernst
Zu der Zeit, wo ich jung war
Eines der gehyptesten Filme überhaupt war Titanic.
So.
Später
Haben die Mädels dann nicht mehr Titanic geguckt.
Sondern Twilight.
Oh ganz ehrlich.
Seriously.
Wenn ich die Auswahl habe
Zwischen Titanic oder Twilight
Da fällt meine Wahl
Immer auf Titanic.
Auch wenn ich jetzt
Fight Club.
Ja klar hab ich das geguckt.
Auch wenn ich nicht unbedingt jetzt Titanic mir jedes Jahr nochmal angucken müsste.
Aber wenn ich wirklich die Auswahl hätte
Zwischen Twilight und Titanic
Dann würd ich Titanic nehmen.
Ähm
Fight Club war nice.
Ich muss aber sagen
Also mein
Mein absoluter Lieblingsfilm
Ich hab es wahrscheinlich schon oft genug erzählt.
Aber
Mein absoluter Lieblingsfilm ist Matrix.
Und zwar der erste von
Ist er glaube ich.
Ja
Bester
Bester Film
Den gucke ich mir fast einmal im Jahr noch an.
Matrix ist der beste Film überhaupt.
Es gibt viele
Das will ich nicht sagen.
Also mein persönlicher Lieblingsfilm.
Heißt nicht dass es
Dass mir nicht andere Sachen auch gefallen.
Aber Matrix ist wirklich so ein Ding.
Es gibt wenig Filme
Die kann ich mir immer mal wieder
So einmal alle 1-2 Jahre angucken.
So Leute.
Ich muss mal kurz
Mein
Mein Headset umstöpseln.
Sonst
Ich
Ich muss euch mal muten.
Weil
Sonst
Knackst
Gleich
Ganz eklig
Laut
So
Da bin ich wieder.
Hört sich
Hört sich auch gleich viel besser an.
Viel
Viel cleaner
Und crisper.
Brog
Ganz ehrlich was Filme angeht.
Ich bin
Ich bin da kein großer
Film
Filmliebhaber.
Ich gucke zwar auch mal ganz gerne einen Film.
Ich finde aber selten was.
Was mir wirklich gefällt.
Auch an Serien.
Also es gibt
Es gibt allgemein
Wenig Sachen.
Es gibt ein paar wirklich nice Filme.
Da müsst ihr jetzt mal drüber nachdenken.
Also
Von Animationsfilmen
Wisst ihr was
Was mein
Mit Abstand
Ja
Das war die Zeit wo wir Sachen noch in
In
Xvid
Und Diffix
Und so gezogen haben.
Was mein
Mit Abstand
Liebster
Animationsfilm ist.
Oder mal
Frage an euch.
Was ist euer Lieblingsanimationsfilm?
Und ich mein nicht den
Nicht den
Hoverboard
Spawn
Oder sowas.
Was ist euer
Echt
Echter
Lieblingsanimationsfilm?
Meinetwegen
Können wir da auch
Animes
Dabei erzählen.
Toy Story 1
Toy Story finde ich auch gut.
Okay
Ich würde schon genannt
WALL-E
Meine auch
Und was ich auch
Mega finde
Ist
Monster AG
Wobei
Noch
Bisschen
Early
War
Also
Da siehst du schon
Teilweise
Die technischen
Probleme
Noch
Aber
WALL-E
Ist das weg.
Also
Ich würde sagen
WALL-E
Ist mein
Mein
Mit Abstand
Also mit Abstand
Lieblings
Animationsfilm
Ice
Ice Age
War auch
Cool
Ja
Aber ansonsten
Wie gesagt
Bin ich nicht
So der
Der große
Filme
Gucker
Ich hab
Ich
Das ist
Bei mir ist bei Filmen
Wie bei
Wie bei Spielen
So ähnlich
Ich
Es dauert
Total lang
Bis ich irgendwas
Gefunden hab
Was so genau
Nach meinem
Geschmack ist
Ich mein
Ich guck mir die
Einen oder anderen
Filme
Aber ich finde
Ich finde die
Wenigsten
Filme
Richtig
Geil
Wo ich
Sag
Boah
Alter
Also wenn das
Fertig ist
So nach dem Motto
Film
Durch
Dann sag ich
Dann
Boah
Geil
Ähm
Da gibt's
Wenig
Gibt ein paar
Da sag ich
Ja
Nice
Kann man sich
Durchaus
Angucken
Ah
Schwer zu sagen
Aber
Apropos
Filme
Da
Da fällt mir
Immer wieder ein
Wie
Ge
Gestalkt
Ich
Mich
Mittlerweile
Fühle
Von
Twitter
Amazon
Und
Google
Egal was
Die sagen
Sie scheren
Keine
Daten
Ich glaub denen
Kein Wort
Und zwar
Als es
Damals
Los ging
So mit
Ukraine
Und
Russland
Da hab
Ich mal
Ein bisschen
Auf Twitter
Rum
Gelesen
Was geht denn
Da gerade
So ab
Da hab ich
Die
Ein oder
Anderen
Google
Sachen
Eingegeben
Und
Geguckt
Pass auf jetzt
Kommt
Ich weiß
Super
Keck
Alu
Aber
Da geh
Ich in Prime
Video
Und wisst ihr
Was mir in Prime
Video
Empfohlen
Wird
Jagd
Auf
Rote
Oktober
Das kann
Kein
Zufall
Sein
Random
Ein Film
Von
Frag
Mich
Nicht
Oder
So
Keine
Ahnung
Random
Einfach
An
Überhaupt
Nichts
Wahrscheinlich
Einfach
Nur weil ich
Irgendwie
Russland
Gegoogelt hab
Oder
Auf Twitter
Gesucht hab
Als da los
Ging
Jagd
Auf
Rote
Oktober
Ich mein
Realistischer
Betrachtet
Anstatt
Keck
Alu
Realistischer
Betrachtet
Ist es
So
Es
Geht
Akt
Es
Gibt
Action
Wo
Russland
Was
Mit
Zu tun
Hat
Und
Die
Leute
Suchen
Dann halt
Auf
Amazon
Mehr
Nach
Ähm
Russischen
Sachen
Und
Deswegen
Er
Wird
Dann
Auch
So
Filme
Empfohlen
Aber
Also
Da war ich
Da war
Da hab
Ich
Mir
Echt
Gedacht
Leute
Ihr
Könnt
Mir
Nicht
Erzählen
Dass
Ihr
Keine
Werbedaten
Irgendwie
Austauscht
Einmal
Nach
Was
Russischem
Gesucht
Bäm
Filmempfehlung
Ja
Die
Vorschläge
Sind
Meistens
Übelst
Müll
Avatar
Werde
Ich
Mir
Nicht
Antun
Ich
Hab
Avatar
Auch
Jahre
Nach
Dem
Des
Raus
Gekommen
Ist
Gesehen
Und
Mir
Gedacht
Okay
Haha
Next
Was
Ist
Eigentlich
Chat
Gehe
Mal
Eine
Frage
An die
Etwas
Jüngeren
Unter
Euch
Was
Ist
Dann
Eigentlich
So
Das
Titanic
Und
Twilight
Der
Heutigen
Zeit
Was
Gucken
Sich
Die
Mädels
Heute
15 Mal
An
Im
Kino
Oder
Über
Streaming
Es
Gibt
Immer
Jede
Generation
Hat
Sowas
Bei
Meiner
Mutter
Was
Dirty
Dancing
Und
Sowas
Barbie
Ist kein
Ist
Kein
So
Love
Äh
Frauen
Film
Glaub
Ich
Nicht
Oder
Frozen
Okay
Ja
Vielleicht
Okay
Aber
Wer
Zählt
Zu
Den
Jüngeren
Okay
Es
Kann
Ich
Euch
Genau
Sagen
Wer
Zu
Den
Jüngeren
Zählt
Und
Zwar
Wann
Kam
Twilight
Raus
Okay
Also
Wenn
Du
Twilight
Nicht
Mehr
Als
High
Film
Mitbekommen
Hast
Dann
Zählst
Du
Zu
Den
Jüngeren
Ich
Weiß
Wirklich
Nicht
Was
Du
Heute
Ja
Gut
Du
Kannst
Auf der
Welt
Gewesen
Sein
Mit
Fünf
Interessiert
Man
Sich
Dafür
Nicht
Also
Ich
Mein
Wenn
Ihr
Du
So
Irgendwie
Zwass
Zwischen
Zwölf
Und
Sechzehn
Sowas
Ich
Auch
Nicht
Bin
Für
Mich
Auch
Nicht
Ich
I
hat er auch noch sehr viele ja ganz ganz praktische effekte zum beispiel dieser
dieses dieser lobby shootout den es da gab unten in der bank oder was das ist
die szene die jeder aus matrix kennt da wo die ganze ganzen kacheln und so
abplatzen das ist auch nahezu wenn nicht komplett ohne cgi gefilmt und da zeigen
wir auch im making of wie sie das gedreht haben so mit mit mit mit seilen
wo sie die wo sie leute dann durch die luft gezogen haben und solche dinger und
und wer sich fragt warum neo in matrix 1 so gut wie nur so gut wie nie kickt
außer ganz am ende was sie auch ganz am ende aufgenommen haben
neo kickt so gut wie wie nie neo boxt im endeffekt nur und schlägt es liegt
daran weil sich kiano reeves irgendwie sein bein verletzt hat entweder während
dem dreh oder vor dem dreh und er konnte nicht richtig kicken
die waren schon vor das überhaupt auch sich ordentlich bewegen konnte also
matrix ist eines der wenigen film wo ich jetzt wo ich das making of geguckt
habe und ich fand das fand ich auch in matrix mega nice dass man irgendwie
wusste dass dass der typ einen hintergeht oder dass dass der typ die
hintergeht aber es war doch gut gemacht also seriously zum ersten mal wo ich den
dude gesehen habe habe ich mir gedacht okay der hat drei gramm stecken das hast
du sofort gesehen das war ein bisschen wie in alten filmen früher wenn der held
irgendeinen schwarzen kumpel hatte wusstest du sofort oder irgendwie einen
schwarzen partner hattest wusstest du sofort okay der wird gleich
angeschossen oder sowas und bei matrix war es auch so als ich den typ gesehen
habe ich habe wie hieß das cypher hieß er glaube ich oder ist das cypher der
typ da wusste ich gleich der hintergeht die ja das kann sein
der erste trans den habe ich auch geguckt ja das ging das ging auch klar
und wisst ihr wisst ihr welcher film mich also es gab es gab ein paar sachen
die mich die mich die letzten jahre über so überrascht überrascht haben aber ein
film mit dem ich nie gerechnet hätte dass er was taugt ist der letzte
dungeons and dragons film als ich das als ich den trailer gesehen habe und
beziehungsweise die ankündigung habe ich Leute das wird ultra schrott und
als den trailer gesehen habe ich mir gedacht okay es sieht gar nicht so kacke
aus aber trailer sind oftmals viel besser aus wird bestimmt mega kacke ich
hatte überhaupt keinerlei hoffnung darin dass da ein gescheiter film rauskommt
und ich muss sagen der ist wirklich nicht übel also wer auch so fantasy
sachen steht also fantasy sachen die vielleicht auch mal zwischendurch ein
bisschen lustig sind aber eigentlich an sich dann doch eine ernste story haben
kann ich echt empfehlen viel viel besser als ich gedacht habe ja und wer so auf
star trek science fiction sachen steht weil ich gerade im im chat lese wer es
noch nicht geguckt hat ich hoffe da gibt es eine vierte staffel
bald noch wäre schade wenn ich aber das noch nicht geguckt hat dem kann ich auch
staffel 1 2 3 tatsächlich empfehlen finde ich finde ich auch nice weil ich
persönlich staffel 1 am besten fand aber die andere gehen auch voll klar also
wer so auf die alten star trek sachen steht der wird das hier gefallen so gut
eigentlich wollte ich mich da gar nicht drüber auslassen aber wenn wir schon
mal dabei sind heute ich bin immer noch am überlegen welches fahrrad ich mir
kaufe haben wir hier irgendwelche poggers poggers fahrradfahrer unter uns also ich
habe ich habe mir mal ein bisschen auf reddit auf reddit geguckt und also was
ich machen will ist also eine sache die ganz gut klingt ist das teil hier
ich will nämlich das für unter unterschiedlichste unterschiedlichste
sachen benutzen ich will waldwege fahren können damit ich will damit aber auch
von der arbeit zurückfahren können und alle auch auf straßen fahren also etwas
relativ vielseitiges ja da muss man raus ich finde ich finde das hier eigentlich
ganz gut preisleistungsmäßig ist auch ganz nice aber ich finde das hier auch
eigentlich ganz gut preisleistungsmäßig ist auch ganz nice das kostet irgendwas
zwischen 2000 zwischen zwei wo steht es denn hier zwischen 2000 und 2500 je
nachdem was man nimmt aber ich will kein e-bike ja aber also also erstens sind die
sind die ziemlich ziemlich schwer lieferbar also ziemlich alle sondern das
zweite ist ich muss gucken wie ich das mache weil nimm keinen carbon rahmen
habe ich auch nicht warum nicht aber habe ich auch nicht vor dass es das ist
ein alu rahmen hat aber eine carbon gabel das hat irgendwie ein bisschen
gehen mal auf bike was bike minus components ich will das ja auch aus
fitness also ich will das zu 90 prozent aus fitness gründen fahren ab und zu
mal vielleicht irgendwie zum liedl oder so aber also eine sache die mir noch ein
bisschen kopfzerbrechen macht beim fahrrad also bei beim fahrradkauf ist ich
habe mir überlegt also ich muss ich muss ja irgendwie dass das in meinen
tagesablauf so ein bisschen einbauen ab und zu dass ich fahrrad fahren kann und
ich habe mir überlegt ich werde das so machen ich fahre dann einfach morgens
mit dem zug da ist noch nicht allzu viel los und gerade fahrradabteil ist
eigentlich immer genug platz ich fahre morgens mit dem zug nach frankfurt ich
habe ein auto aber ich will kein auto fahren um fit zu werden also das ergibt
ja wenig sinn ich habe jetzt angefangen seit über einem
monat schon jeden zweiten tag ordentlich zu rennen
ich meine ich mache zwar schon die letzten jahre über was aber noch nicht
so nicht so oft und ich habe mega bock auf fahrrad fahren und ich habe das
überlegt ich steige die bahn nehme das fahrrad morgens mit und dann fahre ich
einfach zurück mittags ist kein ding fahrrad also strecke ist ungefähr 24
kilometer 23 24 kilometer und da brauche ich dann so was weiß ich eineinhalb
stunden oder sowas für ich weiß ich kann es schlecht einschätzen wie viel
man da als nicht so geübter fahrradfahrer braucht ich werde das
vorher auf jeden fall mal ausprobieren und zumindest ein ding ist halt
normalerweise habe ich einen rucksack dabei rucksack ist dabei rucksack ist
drin mein laptop kopfhörer ladekabel und und und eine kurze hose zum zum
umziehen also nicht so viel als ist jetzt auch nicht super schwer der rucksack
aber ich will kein fahrrad fahren mit rucksack da drehste durch das heißt im
endeffekt brauche ich irgendwie eine möglichkeit dort noch ein paar taschen
anzubringen ich will kein e-bike ich will treten
ja auf das ding habe ich keinen bock mit fest installiertem licht licht will ich
bei bedarf dran machen können und und irgendwelche schutzbleche bräuchte da
muss ich halt gucken wie ich da wie ich da irgendwie eine seitentasche oder so
dran kriegt für den weg heim also die strecke von frankfurt nach hanau ja
inzwischen großen rucksack ist nervig gerade wenn man so fitness mäßig fährt
und dann schwitzt und rucksack auf dem rücken hat das sagt also ich will es
ja nicht übertreiben das wollte ich jetzt sagen was ist ums
eck für mich was ist ums eck für mich was meinst du schutzblech würde ich
schulden sonst ist ein arsch nass wenn die straße nass ist gut aber sowas kann
man im nachhinein auch dann auch dran machen ja wir haben einen eigenen
fahrrad fahrrad ist kein wirklicher keller vereignet also in der firma so
einen eigenen fahrrad abstellraum irgendwas irgendwas wollte ich doch
gerade noch ansprechen ja machen das würde mich würde mich
interessieren ja also kommt es kommt darauf stark an
wie rauf die strecke als die strecke von frankfurt nach hanau hat über die
gesamten 24 kilometer 70 meter steigung also du kannst sagen die ist ziemlich
flach die ist nach die ist quasi eben jetzt halbe stunde 40 minuten
naja also dass du die strecke in unter einer stunde fast packst musst du über
30 km h im durchschnitt fahren vielleicht für jemanden der jetzt nicht
so super gibt es im fahrrad fahren nicht so das ding als e-bike vielleicht
ne ich will ich will kein reines rennrad weil ich will ja auch waldwege
und andere strecken fahren so zu zum größten teil aber ab und zu will ich
halt auch mal von frankfurt zurückfahren mittags heim ja ach nee danach habe ich
doch gerade schon geguckt das habe ich habe ich doch sogar schon gezeigt hast
du mittlerweile ein sixpack gibt es in der firma duschen ja aber wie gesagt ich
fahre nicht auf die arbeit mit dem fahrrad ich fahre von der arbeit heim
mit dem fahrrad hast du schon unterschiedliche shops angeguckt ja wie
kommt das ich weiß ich weiß noch nicht genau welches mir kaufen soll ja genau
so habe ich das geplant bietet ein ag jobrat an ja aber ich will nicht dass
man arbeitgeber irgendwie das es gibt kein bock ich kaufe ein fahrrad fertig
ist ich mein okay seriously es ist jetzt nicht billig ja okay 2000 bis 2500 euro
sind nicht billig für ein fahrrad aber wirklich angemessener preis und außerdem
leute irgendwas muss ich mir von der kohle doch auch mal kaufen
ja ich kann das nicht alles immer vergammeln lassen und nur etfs kaufen
ja da bezahlt wahrscheinlich den namen mit mit schutzplatten eigentlich eigentlich
nicht mich mich juckt das ehrlich ist also schutzblech hätte ich mal gedacht
brauchst du nicht weil ob die hohs nass wird oder so juckt mich nicht ich ziehe
das ich sehe was anderes auf einmal mich an
nee definitiv kein e-bike kannst du etfs empfehlen ich kann dir den etf empfehlen
den ich habe und wo ist mein handy ach fuck hab ich im klo vergessen ich habe einen all
world erstes ding msci all world accumulating das ist das ist ja das ist der braindead etf
den man immer kaufen kann wenn man keinen plan hat so wie ich hat das hat das fahrrad
wifi naja ich habe mein handy dabei also wie gesagt ich habe schon gesehen dass das thema
fahrrad ist fast wie ein fass ohne boden ja man muss ja dann auch gucken dass man
noch passende reflektor aufkleber dran macht und sowas ach mal gucken ich also ich gehe
davon aus dass ich mir irgendwie sowas sowas hier in der richtung in der richtung kaufen
werde ob mit einmal elf oder zweimal elf weiß ich noch nicht genau mal gucken so
und hier bei component sollte ich mal gucken alle cookies akzeptieren
weiß so sie stimmt zu ok angebote komponenten angebote fahrräder ich
sollte vielleicht bei fahrer e-bikes rennräder gravel bike
die dinger sagen wir überhaupt gar nichts jetzt geht es aber langsam schon ins geld
ich werde mir das mal bookmarken ich werde mir das mal bookmarken und ich komme darauf
zurück schon mal nice unser lager muss ja also was mir aufgefallen ist bei vielen anderen
herstellern dass die teilweise zehn wochen oder drei bis zehn wochen lieferzeit haben
oder manchmal auch gar nichts irgendwie gerade liefern weiß nicht was da was da los ist also
ich kann dir schon mal ungefähr meine also ich kann dir sagen was ich ungefähr brauche also
ich bin 1 74 groß und ich habe vergessen ich habe ich habe ich habe den weg in den
schritt schon gemessen aber ich weiß es gerade aus dem kopf nicht ich brauche wahrscheinlich
drei was ist das 53 cm oder sowas jetzt glaube ich größe ist das größe m ach ich weiß es nicht
ich bin 1 74 also sprich ich brauche ich brauche jetzt keine riesen fahrrad ok
fahrrad tierlist ja das wäre ja aber so sieht es aus also demnächst bin ich auch mit fahrrad
unterwegs ich bin gestern ich bin gestern 8 über 8 8,2 oder so kilometer gelaufen zum
ersten mal also längste längste runde überhaupt mit ungefähr 77 minuten pro kilometer und ich
hätte noch eine ganze ecke schneller gekonnt hätte ich wirklich vollgas gegeben bin eigentlich
relativ entspannt gerannt wenn ich mir überlege dass ich bei sieben minuten den kilometer vor
einem monat noch gestorben wäre auch wenn ich nur ein kilometer gerannt wäre ich finde ich ist
der progress schon ganz okay ich laufe ja und fahr fahrrad da müsst ihr noch schwimmen dann
dann next iron man wie kam es zu der entscheidung sport zu machen das ist eine sehr gute frage
ja dann leute wo kriege ich die spritzen her also das ist das ist eine wirklich sehr gute
frage wie kam es zu der entscheidung sport zu machen also so hundertprozentig kann ich das
gar nicht sagen ich kann ich kann also ich kann es mir aber mal versuchen so so herzuleiten also
ich meine was ich jetzt ja schon lange mache sogar schon vor corona ist dass ich jeden tag
und mit jeden tag meine ich wirklich jeden tag außer außer manchmal sonntags aber sonst wirklich
jeden tag egal ob arbeiten oder nicht und und was auch dank homeoffice erst so richtig möglich ist
dass ich jeden tag eineinhalb stunden wandern mindestens eine halb stunden wandern gegangen
bin nicht nicht super langsam aber auch nicht mega schweißtreibend schnell aber ordentlich zügig
ja so und irgendwann habe ich mir dann so mal gedacht ok max weiß was das somal testen wie
wie viel ausdauer du eigentlich mittlerweile hast also wie weit kannst du eigentlich rennen ich
habe das jahrelang nicht ausprobiert und ich dachte mir so hey nach dem valomat könnten wir
könnten wir vielleicht machen ja bin mir nicht sicher ob ich da heute brain kapazitäten für
habe so und weißt du was lass doch mal ausprobieren hast du es nie getestet so deine deine tägliche
runde und so die geht richtig richtig gut von statten ich ich habe mir dann irgendwann auch so
eine garmen fitness tracker uhr gekauft und hat ein paar mal aufgezeichnet dabei und hat mir so
gedacht ja so eigentlich alles ganz nice doch sieht doch alles ganz gut aus und dann habe ich einfach
gesagt ok ich renne jetzt einfach mal ich habe einfach von heute auf morgen gesagt ich renne
jetzt mal so erste runde weiß ich noch mega brutal erste runde glaubt war nur fünf kilometer oder
sowas und ich bin die nicht durchgehend gerannt ich bin vor den fünf kilometern glaube ich weiß
ich dreimal ein kilometer gerannt oder so und leute wir haben die beine weh getan die füße die
oberschenkel die sogar mir hat man kann man kann es sich kaum vorstellen wir haben meine ärme weh
getan vom laufen fragt man sich jetzt warum tun einem die ärme weh vom laufen aber ja allein schon
wenn man da auch ärme für braucht beim rennen so hin und her und so alles weh getan da habe ich
erst mal drei vier tage nix gemacht weil ich muskelkater erst fack hatte und dann habe ich mir
überlegt okay eigentlich lief das besser als gedacht weil ich habe ich weiß früher hatte
ich schon problemen kilometer durchzurennen und jetzt mit knapp 40 und ich bin ewig ewig nicht
gerannt also man früher habe ich mehr gepackt so und dann ok weißt du was jetzt probierst du das
einfach noch mal jetzt jetzt jetzt machst du es einfach noch mal und dann habe ich ganz weiß was
du läufst jetzt einfach so so so schnell aber das heißt nicht so schnell du kannst so schnell wie
geht so dass du fünf kilometer durch gerannt kriegst und das habe ich auch first try geschafft
ich war aber danach ultra im arsch wieder also wirklich wir haben die wahren weg alles alles
weh getan so alles also komplett mir hat mir hat sogar meinen nacken weh getan es hat mir alles
ärmer bei ich wusste gar nicht ich wusste nicht mal dass einem fußzehen wehtun können das war
mir nicht klar bis zu dem zeitpunkt dass das überhaupt möglich ist dass man fußzeh schmerzen
haben kann zumindest das lag aber auch hauptsächlich daran dass ich das in so 0 8 15 turen schuhen
gerannt bin ohne jegliche dämpfung oder irgendwas und auch noch ausgeleiert dazu so und dann habe
ich mir gedacht wieder zwei drei tage später weißt du was max das lief jetzt auch besser als gedacht
du machst jetzt einfach in dem tempo weiter jeden zweiten tag und seitdem das ist jetzt
ungefähr ungefähr so vielleicht eins eineinhalb monate her renne ich jeden zweiten tag manchmal
ist es ist es jeden zweiten dann jeden dritten tag wenn ich beispielsweise auf die arbeit muss und
mittags so heiß ist aber mein ziel ist und das klappt auch in 90 prozent der fälle jeden jeden
zweiten tag und mittlerweile ist es so rennen oder laufen rennen also gut joggen ja also nicht laufen
gelaufen mache ich schon eine weile aber halt schnell schneller als einfach nur gehen ja oder
einfach nur als einfach nur spazieren gehen als einfach nur auf also man kann sich jetzt streiten
ob es ob es joggen ist oder schon rennen gibt ja da diskussionen drüber ab wann man rennt ab wann
man noch joggt aber letztendlich in meiner fitness watch wähle ich running aus und mittlerweile ist
es tatsächlich so gut geworden dass ich wenn ich wenn ich gerannt bin den tag merke ich noch übelst
auch teilweise so in den beinen wenn ich treppe runterlaufen sowas und den tag danach danach merke
ich es auch noch ein bisschen aber den tag dann wenn ich wieder dran bin mit mit rennen ist eigentlich
fast alles wieder weg und dass das er hat das ist jetzt so seit den letzten seit der letzten
zwei wochen ist das so also es hat sich immer weiter gebessert und ich kann jetzt quasi jeden
zweiten tag rennen ohne dass mir noch das rennen vom letzten mal in den beinen wehtut wenn ich
wieder anfange also läuft ganz gut also ich finde für knappen modus aber doch monats aber eine halb
monate ist das eigentlich ganz gut also mein schnellstes meine schnellste runde fünf kilometer
war fünf minuten weil sich 55 oder sowas und jetzt also mein mein ziel ist mein kurz oder
kurz mittelfristiges ziel ist zehn kilometer unter einer stunde und ich glaube da bin ich bin
ich sogar echt auf einem guten weg ich bin letztens acht kilometer gerannt oder 8,2 kilometer schön so
entspannt wie ging mit sieben minuten ziemlich genau sieben minuten pro kilometer das heißt
wenn ich wenn ich mich mal ein bisschen an die geschwindigkeit ein bisschen an die länge gewöhnt
habe denke ich ist das durchaus realistisch noch sagen wir mal 1,8 kilometer weiter und ein bisschen
schneller zu laufen wobei man sagen muss das täuscht das hätte ich selbst nicht gedacht
der unterschied zwischen sieben auf sechs minuten ist wirklich enorm also denkt man sich so so eine
minute schneller halt mal ein bisschen anstrengend bisschen schwitzen 7 minuten ist easygoing sieben
minuten pro kilometer sechs minuten pro kilometer ist echt anstrengend das glaubt man gar nicht so
wenn man das selbst noch nicht erlebt hat der unterschied ist wirklich riesig also sieben
sieben minuten pro kilometer sind so naja man könnte jetzt irgendwann auch mal wieder schluss
machen und sechs minuten pro kilometer oder knapp unter sechs minuten weil man muss ja ein bisschen
puffer haben da so 45 pro kilometer ist so ist so nach dem ersten kilometer schon alter wann ist
endlich vorbei das gefühl dass ich unendlich lang laufen konnte naja also bei bei den längeren bei
den längeren runden so letztens die acht kilometer runde wo ich schon langsam gelaufen bin die hätte
ich auch zehn kilometer rennen können ja wobei ich halt auch schon ein bisschen in den beinen dann
gemerkt habe aber das war recht entspannt aber bei bei dem letzten wo ich halt versucht habe wie
schnell schaffst du fünf kilometer da hatte ich keine zeit high zu sein da war ich nach dem ersten
kilometer schon im alter wann ist endlich vorbei modus ich konnte ich wohne neben frankfurt ich
komme nicht direkt aus frankfurt garantiert werde ich das nicht testen naja auf schwimmen habe ich
keinen bock früher es ist eigentlich witzig wie sich die wie sich da so die die vorlieben ändern
früher habe ich ihre laufen gehen richtig gehasst fahrrad fahren war ganz okay aber schwimmen war
mega schwimmen konnte ich damals auch richtig gut ich konnte echt ohne scheiß ich konnte
wahrscheinlich ich weiß nicht was mein was mein meistes war aber ich hätte ohne probleme zehn
kilometer schwimmen können also 55 kilometer plus konnte ich easy schwimmen damals war überhaupt
kein ding ich konnte ich konnte da muss ich zwei stunden im wasser schwimmen das war überhaupt
kein ding und jetzt war ich bestimmt 15 jahre so nicht beim schwimmbad hat keinen bock mehr zu
schwimmen also jetzt ausweg ich habe gerade meinen chat irgendwie gerade verklickt wo ist mein chat
schwimmen habe ich keinen bock hörst du musik während dem laufen die meisten leute die mir so
entgegenkommen morgens am main die haben irgendwas auf dem ohr manche sind so richtig elite aus mir
kommt manchmal so ein opa entgegen ich habe keine ahnung wie alt er ist weil ich noch nie sein
gesicht richtig gesehen habe aber ich glaube der schon ein bisschen älter manche kommt mir morgens
so ein opa entgegen gerannt ja irgendwie einen drittel so schnell wie ich aber ist kein ding der
ist wahrscheinlich auch fast doppelt so alt oder so da wobei er 80 wird er nicht sein aber es hat
ist eine ganze ecke älter aber da hat die der hat die die ultra elite ausrüstung da der hat
so ein komisches käppi was oben frei ist dann hat er so eine richtig nice verspiegelte sonnenbrille
an dann hat er in so komischen so einen trikot an so eine so eine tasche nebendran der hat die
ultra professionelle ausrüstung der kerl und nichts und nichts ja und und und und musik und
alles ist voll ausgestattet und ich sehe dagegen übelst reudig aus ich habe eine kappe auf
den china chinesen funktions t-shirt und eine kurze hose das war es nichts kein musik kein
sonst was das und das einzige was ich unter was ich unter dem t-shirt habe ist so ein so ein so ein
gurt wo man das handy rein machen kann max liegt sein aussehen und nein ich habe mir so einen so
einen laufen handy tasche so ein ding gekauft sowas sowas hier in der richtung ja das ist
eigentlich ganz nice das kannst du nämlich ziemlich eng machen und ziemlich das liegt
dann ziemlich eng an und das mache ich also hier die haben das oben drüber ich habe das unter
auch nicht vorne sondern auf dem rücken ich drehe das immer auf den rücken und mach es und das und
das hemmt aber ich habe ich habe weder sonnenbrille noch musik noch irgendwas aber manche sehen mega
professionell aus die mir entgegenkommen na gut das mobil das handy habe ich allein schon deswegen
dabei wenn man wirklich irgendwas ist unterwegs ja überlegt euch mal man knickt um und hat kein
handy dabei oder so oder schon kacke kein tacho ich ich mache mir so ein fahrradcomputer vorne
dran ja sowas welches tier hat zehn augen aber kann man nicht sehen das sind so fragen die nicht
gemacht sind sie zu erraten aber ich bin mir sicher du wirst das gleich erzählen du meintest
doch dass du während einer ausbildung noch einer schlankeren was ist korrekt war ich auch das heißt
aber nicht dass ich gut in form gewesen bin während der ausbildung ich war nur nicht so dick wie die
anderen es waren die zeiten wo sie felix und mich noch in enge technikräume geschickt haben weil wir
die einzigen waren die durchgepasst haben ohne die kabel aus den switchen rauszureißen mit mit dem
bauch watch mit lte ich nehme das handy mit die sind dann verloren gegangen wenn sie sich das bein
gebrochen haben unterwegs aber genug genug erzählt jetzt also demnächst demnächst fahrradstelz am
start ich sag so ich bin ich bin fest fest davon überzeugt ja ich kauf mir ich bin ich weiß nur
nicht genau was und wo und ich will halt auch irgendwas lieferbares haben man of cultures united
hier wieder aber was haben wir denn hier schon das kann man so irgendwas angucken auch noch
eineinhalb stunden zeit was haben wir denn hier day fix titanfall 2 and it's amazing lasst mich
raten ok jack frags video solange wenn ich level captain baited werden was haben die denn gefixt
die haben gefixt dass die server gd dost werden und zu gesperrt von irgendwelchen komischen tut
so dass es nicht mehr spielbar ist ja ich bezweifle dass das lange hält dass da irgendwas
gefixt wird obwohl sie jetzt mit apex eigentlich das geld hätten mal wenigstens titanfall ein
bisschen ein bisschen in form zu bringen samt zockt hat neues video über unity torsten das
ist gut da macht der macht gute videos und das interessiert mich was der der tod von unity
das interessiert mich das oh leute mein ich habe zu viele taps konform ich habe zu viele taps mehr
taps mehr taps als chrome darstellen kann ok machen wir erst mal die ganzen shit hierzu
close close close gerade noch so geschaffte perfekt ist hier zeit was zu ändern ach das
ist ich dachte ich habe mich schon gewundert seit wann heißt der channel so ach das ist
nicht native web sondern privater channel ach so ok dann lass uns doch mal kurz gucken was
sagt er denn zu der der tod von unity also wenn ich in der deutschsprachigen so youtube szene
einem vertrau fachkundig was zum thema unity zu sagen dann ist es er da bin ich mal gespannt
ob er ob er sagt dass unity jetzt also ob er in das in dieses unity wird sterben einstimmt
oder ob er sagen wird alles übertrieben kurz lautstärke checken ich habe viele bescheute
sachen gesehen die firmen in der videospielbranche versuchen durchzusetzen was unity plant ist aber
so ziemlich das bescheuertste und absolut dümmste dass ich je gesehen habe noch ist das die ist das
die plans was das zombies musik aber so ziemlich das bescheuertste und absolut dümmste dass ich
je gesehen habe ja nie habe ich es erlebt wie die entscheidung einer firma so komplett an dem was
möglich und sinnvoll ist vorbeigeht unity technologies die firma hinter den autoren system
unity verändert ihr lizenzmodell was womöglich illegal ist in mehrerlei hinsicht aber dazu
kommen wir doch laut dem neuen lizenzmodell wisst ihr was ich mich frage wie machen die das mit
spielen im game pass erwarten die ernsthaft dass microsoft ist ab 1.1 neue lizenzgebühren bezahlt
oder wie der gaming clerks du ja aber ich glaube der hat damit gar nichts mehr zu tun auch schon
ewig nicht mehr geguckt glaube der ich glaube der ist sogar komplett raus da mittlerweile soll
der vertreiber eines spiels bis zu 20 cent pro installation das habe ich verpasst modell soll
der vertreiber eines spiels bis zu 20 cent pro installation der vertreiber das wäre das wäre
dann quasi microsoft für den game pass eine spielzahlen wenn er die schwelle von 200.000
dollar verdienst und 200.000 installationen überschreitet und ja es geht um installationen
nicht dem kauf eines spiel ok das heißt das heißt im endeffekt auch irgendwelche free games ok
das heißt man müsste für slender auf einmal was bezahlen weil installationen und so falls
ich da jemand noch daran erinnert kennt ihr noch kennt ihr noch diese diese videos wo die leute
sich alle so super krass fake erschreckt haben denn pro verkauften spiel würde ja noch irgendwo
sinn machen wenn jemand ein spiel via steam runter geht auf seinem pc und dann noch ein
weiteres mal auf sein steam deck sind das zwei installationen die an nötige zeit werden müssen
das ist so absurd ja das ist wirklich dämlich mindestens eine sache einfällt wodurch diese
idee wie ein kartenhaus in sich zusammenfällt aber gehen wir ob wenn die rudern da wieder
zurück in einem monat oder so und sagen ihr habt uns alle falsch verstanden wie wir
apologize we listen to the community bla bla bla kommt the community is the most important
and most valuable bla bla bla bla bla kommt bestimmt wieder in einem monat oder sowas
paar probleme mal durch mal davon abgesehen dass sie schon war geist mit den genauen details was
schlecht ist da diese regel aber schläft der dude oder was ist mit dem los die sehr vage ist mit
den genauen der ist auch am pennen oder der haben sie doch eine leiche hingestellt das ist doch das
ist doch computer generator oder details was schlecht ist da diese regel ab 1. januar 2024
in kraft treten soll sind die dinge die wir wissen technisch gar nicht möglich zum beispiel wurde
ursprünglich gesagt dass jede installation geld kostet du lehnt auf steam das spiel runter
status ist es wird ein ping an den unity server geschickt und der entwickler beziehungsweise
vertreiber des spiels muss 20 cent zahlen solltest du das spiel das offizielle statement ok das
kommt uns jetzt einmal kurz an ich wusste ich schwöre ich habe dieses date mir noch nicht
gesehen es ist einfach so lächerlich leute seriously ernsthaft ich kann ich habe diese
statement nicht gelesen aber diese statements sind immer der exakt gleiche marketing text
nur leicht abgeändert es ist immer exakt der gleiche scheiß ihr müsst mal lesen habt ihr
die entschuldigung gelesen für herr der ringe gollum das ist auch genau ein bisschen länger
aber genau der gleiche scheiß ja guckt euch die guckt euch das zeug an die guckt euch die
marketing messages an die blizzard rausgehauen hat wo es da um sexuelle belästigung bei blizzard
ging der genau der gleiche bullshit text immer ich habe das gefühl es gibt so eine master
marketing ja lücken text ausfüll software und da kommt dann so zeug raus bei ok lasst mal kurz
gucken lasst mal lesen wie erfahrt you we apologize voll konfiguren moment sie apologize doch okay
leute es kann sein dass jedes kam heute habe ich definitiv noch nicht gelesen we apologize for the
confusion das bedeutet im endeffekt eigentlich nur sie sagen sie machen es genauso wie jetzt
sie apologize für dass die leute angeblich zu dumm sind es zu verstehen aber ich gehe mal davon
aus die leute wenn es zum größten teil schon richtig verstanden haben we apologize for the
confusion and angst the runtime fee policy we announced on tuesday caused we are listening
talking to our team members community customers and partners and will be making changes to the
policy okay da kommt da so was we will share an update in a cup in a couple of days thank you
for your honest and critical feedback in wirklichkeit denkt er das bedeutet sowie fickt euch alle gehen
uns auf den sack übrigens sie sollen es war mit dem typ diskassen der morddrohungen an unity selbst
geschickt hat es gab doch es gab doch die news post dass es morddrohungen gab an das unity team
und danach hat sich herausgestellt es war jemand selbst aus dem unity team also diese entscheidung
scheint auch sehr viel rückhalt in der firma selbst zu haben okay lasst uns das video weiter
gucken der entwickler beziehungsweise vertreiber des spiels muss 20 cent zahlen solltest du das
spiel löschen und erneut installieren werden das weitere 20 cent das ist ja mal super bescheuert
nochmals das ist ja mal ultra beknackt alter was haben sie sich da denn ausgedacht die begründung
dafür war dass unity ja nicht checken könnte wer das spiel mehrmals installiert die daten
anonym sind ja und ja und was das für eine begründung ja das ist ungefähr so wie wenn
ich sage leute also ihr müsst mir jetzt alle fünf euro im monat überweisen weil ich kann
ja nicht tracken wer von den nicht angemeldeten zuschauern nicht primes habt das ist genau die
gleiche dämliche logik macht überhaupt keinen sinn jede installation gecheckt wird aha und
später dann als sie zurück ruderten ist es plötzlich doch möglich und nur jedes weitere
gerät soll geld kosten das bedeutet dass unity ende des monats dem entwickler eine rechnung
schickt mit den monatlichen installationen ganz auf der basis von trust me bro woher will man
wissen dass unity nicht scheiße erzählt und mehr installationen schreckt als wirklich passieren
aber darum soll man sich laut der firma keine gedanken natürlich nicht weil wenn dann wird ja
klar weil man diesen idioten auch nur noch ein wort glauben kann vor allem nachdem sie ihre
terms of service illegalerweise geändert haben damit sie überhaupt die möglichkeit besitzen
da wird jetzt wahrscheinlich sich alle freuen dass sie in zukunft mehr c++ für unreal machen
dürfen und godot wird sich auch in ast freuen rate ich jetzt einfach mal ich habe keine ahnung
von spiele engines und spielentwicklung war spontan zu entscheiden ursprünglich wurden
die aktuellen terms of service auf github gepostet öffentlich für alle damit durch
transparenz vertrauen aufgebaut wird immerhin war es so möglich jede minimalste veränderung
der tos zu verfolgen ja dieses wurde vor ein paar monaten offline genommen und dann wurde
klammheimlich die da weißt du doch eigentlich schon dass da irgendwas im argen ist weil wenn
solche sachen verschwinden entfernt die besagt dass man immer unter den jeweiligen terms fällt
von der jeweiligen unity version die man nutzt bedeutet eigentlich sollten ältere unity versionen
nicht unter dieser neuen regel fallen aber durch diese änderung der man ja nicht zugestimmt hat
da man diese heimlich einfügte haben sie nun die möglichkeit zu machen was sie wollen denn
dieses neue lizenzmodell zählt ab januar für alle unity spiele die jemals erschienen sind auch
alte version schwer zu sagen ist halt auch ist es wirklich schwer zu sagen weil es ist erstens die
frage ob alte unity sachen überhaupt diesen tracking code enthalten wo man das tracken kann
ob die sich das nicht nur ausgedacht haben und ich meine es gibt jetzt das wird wahrscheinlich
auch der gedanke dahinter sein es gibt jetzt seit über zehn jahren oder so unity games also das
einzige ziel hinter sowas kann doch sein kurzfristig die zahlen guten besonders gut aussehen zu lassen
und den den ganzen schritten zu verkaufen warum macht man denn sonst sowas würde bedeuten dass
alle spiele bereits ein checker installiert haben und dann ab den ersten ersten aktiviert
werden fast so als wäre es mal wer was doch spannend ist wo unity erst von einem jahr mit
ironsource fusionierte die damals beschuldigt wurden herzustellen frage mich ob der ceo von
ironsource etwas damit zu tun hat immerhin ist er seit dem zusammenschluss von unity und ironsource
der dritte präsident von unity dann haben wir noch zwei weitere präsidenten der firma die
beide mit elon musk zusammenarbeiten einer der verifiziert bescheuerten menschen auf diesem
planeten igen durban zum beispiel war ein maulwurf der bei twitter arbeitete und versuchte
den deal durchzupuschen für elon musk das kam raus und deswegen wurde er gefeuert das ziel
wurde dennoch erreicht und klar haben wir noch den ceo von unity john richie tiello oder wie auch
immer er ausgesprochen wird ist mir egal wie paar nudeln vor dem menschen als dass es mich kümmern
würde damit vorher unity gegen die wand fuhr tat er dasselbe mit er ist bekannt dafür absolut
die komplett gegen die werte von spielern und entwicklern sind wenn es nach ihm ginge würde
man fürs nachladen im bett der war das der typ war das geld zahlen müssen und alle die nicht
über das monetarisieren ihrer spiele nachdenken sind verfickte idioten ich erinnere mich da war
doch was das ist doch gar nicht so lange her klar ja steht ja auch hier 2022 ja ich ich erinnere
mich seine worte nicht meine weil hier ist das was wir auf den kanal schon häufiger thematisiert
haben diese menschen an der spitze der firmen haben keine ahnung von dem was sie verkaufen
sie haben aber ahnung von verkaufen und deswegen bekommen sie absurde summen jedes jahr da sie das
gesicht einer firma sind es entscheiden menschen gut gut dazu muss ich sagen dazu habe ich
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen andere meinung man kann sich sicherlich lange drüber streiten ob
manager gehälter gerechtfertigt sind oder nicht aber was man für sie was man oder warum die
teilweise so über übelst abgedrehte verträge bekommen so nach dem motto zwei jahre reingeschissen
und trotzdem 20 millionen abfindung und sowas das muss man aber glaube ich weniger den manager
oder den den ja top executive leuten da vorhalten sondern eher denjenigen die den vertrag aufgesetzt
haben mit dem typ und unterschrieben haben der kell muss ja quasi in den vorstellungsgespräch
führen wie jeder andere auch jetzt natürlich ist das vorstellungsgespräch nicht gelaufen wie jeder
andere auch aber irgendjemand dort hat den ja eingestellt also sprich die top manager bekommen
ja auch verträge und da sollte man sich mal eher überlegen okay was passiert da eigentlich ich
würde den managern selbst sogar relativ wenig vorwurf machen wenn sie das dann auch in anspruch
nehmen was ihnen in ihren verträgen zugesichert wurde warum es so bescheuerte verträge gibt da
muss man sich mal gedanken gedanken drüber machen und das läuft dann wahrscheinlich darauf raus dass
es eben nicht so viele gibt für diese position und dass die halt mit sowas durchkommen sicherlich
ist da auch viel fetter wirtschaft dabei könnte ich mir vorstellen kennen sich alle vom golf
spielen aber irgendjemand hat den vertrag gemacht dann sollte man vielleicht auch mal die bisschen
halten anstatt nur die manager mario danke für den sub spiel die keine ahnung von videospielen
haben deswegen werden spiele immer anstrengender mehr grind haben mehr micro transactions damit
man sich die kreiniges wegkaufen kann ubi soft kann ich ein lied davon singen probleme in spielen
künstlich zu erzeugen damit man ein spieler die dann wegkaufen kann und das alles währenddessen
die ceos der firmen immer mehr heulen dass spiele machen ja so teuer ist und man deswegen menschen
ausbeuten muss die rein psychologisch anfälliger für diverse maschen sind wie eben lootboxen du
hast also mr. maulwehr zwei elon musk bootlicker und herrn microtransactions an der spitze einer
firma die die meistgenutzte videospiel engine produziert wer hätte gedacht dass das mal
irgendwann nicht mehr gut geht ich meine als die damals hunderte fachleute entlassen hatte unter
anderem das team das ein plattformer entwickelt hatte damit unity checken kann wo lücken in
ihrem letztes battlefield ist da nicht demnächst wieder eine neue season für für bf 20 42 da
kommt man wieder rein man ist das müsste doch jetzt bald bis doch jetzt bald soweit sein existieren
war einfach schon klar dass es ab jetzt immer schlimmer wird ok zurück zum eigentlichen thema
zurück zu den absurden lizenz modell also ja ursprünglich sollte jede installation geld
kosten nun noch jede erste installation auf einem gerät bedeutet jedes spiel muss irgendeine datei
oder registry anlegen damit das gerät nicht einen weiteren ping an den unity server schickt wie das
genau gemacht wird findet irgendwer garantiert innerhalb der ersten 24 stunden raus und dann
passiert das was alle befürchten wenn zum beispiel irgendeine schneeflocke wegen pronomen in einem
videospiel richtig hat das video habe ich auch gesehen ist ja komplett ausgerastet schnappatmung
bekommen anfängt irrational wütend zu werden dann könnte er nun statt review bombing zu betreiben
also absichtlich spielen eine schicht bewertung zu geben das spiel immer wieder neu installieren
damit der entwickler unity irgendwann millionen schuldet laut deren tracking system auf das
niemand zugriff hat außer unity und selbst wenn man nicht so schnell kräftige rausfindet ob es
die erste installation ist kann man einfach ein paar virtual machines erstellen und auf denen
das spiel installieren es gibt nahezu unendlich viele wege dieses system zu umgehen und den
entwickler in den ruin damit zu treiben ebenso stellt euch vor jede installation kostet 20 cent
welche spiele leiden wohl am meisten darunter richtig kleine spiele faire spiele spiele die
sagen wir haben ein cooles spiel aber wir wollen den preis vergestalten und haben auch keine
micro transactions short hike zum beispiel kostet regulär 8 euro und im deal gerne mal 4 euro oder
sogar weniger abgezogen der steuern und gebühren müsste jemand das spiel nur um die zehn mal
installieren damit der komplette gewinn sich auflöst dadurch wird also gefördert dass spiele
erstens grundsätzlich teurer werden müssen und zweitens micro transactions besitzen um diese
gebühr wieder auszudeichen immerhin bedeutet jedes verkaufte spiel für theoretisch immer oder
man macht keine spiele mit unity kosten das dumme ist halt es gibt schon so viele vieles was
sie gar nicht vor durchdacht hatte zum beispiel wurde gefragt wie denn gekräfte spiele sich
auswirken wenn jemand illegal ein spiel runterlädt und installiert dann würde der entwickler ja
sogar dafür zahlen müssen unity sagt dass deren software so toll na klar dass die gekräfte version
erkennen kann wenn das so ist unity warum gibt es dann noch gekräfte spiele wollen die mir
ernsthaft sagen dass sie den weg gefunden haben um zu 100 prozent zu checken dass ein spiel gekräft
wurde ja ganz bestimmt geht wieder in richtung trust me bro oder website spiele also spiele im
browser ursprünglich wurde behauptet dass jeder seiten aufruf dann 20 cent kosten würde weil eine
website applikation zu starten ist ja eine installation da ruderte man zurück und meinte
das ist nun doch kein geld kostet die müssen intern leute haben die über ihre eigene software
bescheid wissen und die solche fragen im vorfeld sicherlich auch schon gestellt haben das heißt
man hat sich auf führungsebene bewusst dazu entschieden diese bedenken erst mal zu ignorieren
und zu gucken ob die leute denn meckern werden nicht zu den installationen zählt geil also
machen wir jetzt alle noch website spiele verdienen uns dumm und dämlich und kommen so nur über die
kostenschwelle aber niemals über die der installationen wodurch unity gar nichts bekommen
würde das ergibt sinn und was ist mit charity bundles sowas wie humble bundle wo spiele für
patient weggegeben werden für den guten zweck ja ja nee also die werden auch nicht getrackt die
sind von den institutionen ausgeschlossen während interne stimmen sagen dass die spitze von unity
vor anscheinend noch nie von charity bundles gehört hat was man nicht mehr deren irgendwie
sinn macht produkte umsonst weggeben für den guten zweck wozu das denn laut diesen stimmen
weiß unity auch noch nicht wie sie zwischen charity keys und normalen keys entscheiden
sollen die werden wahrscheinlich vieles davon nicht wissen wie sie es umsetzen sollen das
wurde entschieden und jetzt ist die frage so nach dem motto ja setzt das mal um ergeben weil nur
noch demos erlaubt sind die nichts mit den vollen spiel zu tun haben sprich demos indem man den
speicherstand in das volle spiel übernehmen kann sind dadurch tabu und ich habe ja hin und wieder
gesagt dass der vertreiber der spiele die kosten tragen muss weil so hat unity es selbst geschrieben
das bedeutet also dass valve nintendo microsoft und sony die 20 cent pro institution zahlen sollen
wenn er so ein spiel im game pass erscheint muss microsoft unity geld zahlen microsoft wird einen
scheiß machen die werden erst mal ihre ihr battalion an anwälten los schicken und unity
so lange auf den sack gehen bis unity kein bock mehr hatten sich von microsoft kaufen best oder
sowas für jede installation ich weiß ja nicht aber ich glaube microsoft wird da nicht zustimmen
keiner wird dazu stimmen innerhalb 24 stunden hat unity es dadurch geschafft alle wirklich alle
anzupissen spieler sind angepisst weil viele der aktuell liebsten spiele in gefahr sind entwickler
sind angepisst weil sie dadurch gezwungen sind drm und malware in ihr spiel zu packen und kosten auf
die zukommen über die sie keine kontrolle haben und publishers angepisst weil jedes spiel nun aus
dem nichts in zusätzliches geld kostet niemand gewinnt hier absolut niemand nicht mal unity weil
die engine jetzt komplett zur ramsch engine verkommt mit der nur noch mobile spiele entwickelt werden
die das geld aus den usern raussaugen damit so viel geld pro installation wie möglich gemacht
wird selbst wenn dieses neue lizenzmodell zurückgenommen wird ist es zu spät kein
entwickler kann unity jemals wieder trauen wenn sie aus dem heiteren himmel nur vier monate im
voraus in der art extreme lizenzänderungen ankündigen ja da ist was wenn man nie wieder
vertrauen und ich rate euch dringend das ebenfalls einzusehen daher werde ich von heute an unity
entwickler nie wieder als erstrebenswerten beruf nennen bleibt fern davon orientiert euch jetzt um
und nicht erst in ein paar jahren ich habe 14 jahre unity erfahrung kennen diese engine in
und auswendig aber auch ich sehe es ein dass es nicht mehr lange gut gehen wird mein aktuelles
spiel wird noch mit unity fertig gemacht es ist unmöglich dieses spiel das für die switch
optimiert wird mit einer anderen engine schnell auf den aktuellen stand zu bringen aber sobald es
fertig und erschienen ist werde auch ich wechseln diese geschichte ist wie ich es am anfang gesagt
habe das absolut bescheuertste was ich je in meinem leben in der videospielbranche mitbekommen
habe so vielen leuten droht nun der ruin und das einzige was die dazu noch zu sagen hatte ist wir
erkennen dass einige verwirrt sind von unserem lizenzmodell lasst uns noch mal genau erklären
dass es genauso scheiße ist wie gedacht denkt da fällt einem nichts mehr zu ein diverse unity
mitarbeiter haben gesagt dass sie intern sehr hart gegen das lizenzmodell sich geäußert haben und
viele kündigen dass sie ebenfalls keine zukunft mehr in der firma sehen nach diesem vertrauensbruch
ist es einfach unmöglich jemals wieder zu vertrauen diese brücke wurde komplett eingerissen
ich wünsche einem viel glück beim wechsel ihre engine es wird nervig für uns alle aber es würde
noch nerviger für noch mehr leute werden wenn wir diesen müll tolerieren würden da bin ich mal
gespannt wie sich das die nächsten monate jahre über entwickelt weil selbst wenn die jetzt komplett
zurückrudern ich meine ich glaube nicht dass es der tod für unity sein wird direkt es gibt aber
hoffentlich den anderen engines ein bisschen mehr boost und ja unity verschwindet dann wohl
verdient in der bedeutungslosigkeit offen das mal aber ist es nicht unity to engine x converter
wenn es so einfach wer chat weil es auch so weil es auch so einfach mal geht ja ja das denke ich
auch ja ja ist ja auch nice unity unity zu gardena wasserschlauch converter haben wir sonst noch
irgendwas schönes windows 12 windows 10 windows 12 das ist doch debate video hoch 10 oder software
entwicklung ist ok acht minuten ich wette mit euch übelstes debate video windows 10 wird das
letzte windows sein das war zumindest der ursprüngliche plan von microsoft das stimmt
überhaupt nicht es geht schon los ja microsoft selbst sagt sie haben das nie gesagt und wenn
man nachguckt ja so offiziell haben sie das nie in irgendeiner mitteilung rausgehauen aber ein
typ aus dem sehr microsoft nahen umfeld hat das rausgehauen aber trotzdem ja schon irgendwie
haben sie das haben sie auch so stehen lassen auf der hauseigenen tech konferenz ignite hatte
man 2015 bekannt gegeben dass nach windows 10 kein neues betriebssystem mehr kommt stattdessen
sollten kleinere und größere updates das programm schnell und modern halten und dann kamen einige
jahre später überraschung windows 11 und auch das wird wohl nicht die haben nicht gesagt dass es
das letzte windows werden wird das stimmt nicht die haben gesagt dass es ein ein ein ein ein
service windows werden soll oder sowas die haben nie diesen diese aussage gebracht meines wissens
nach offiziell von microsoft dass windows 10 das letzte windows werden wird ja natürlich das so
stehen lassen und die haben auch viele sachen gesagt in dieser richtung die man genau so
ich lasse mich aber gerne eines besseren belehren das letzte betriebssystem der amerikaner sein
jedenfalls wenn man das ist der media das ist der kanal von mediamarkt saturn wirklich denn
gerüchteküche um windows 12 glaubt okay eigentlich das übelste sinnloses video dieser release die
fand ja nicht okay okay sie haben absolut auch genauso kein plan wie alle anderen auch mega
sinnloses video jepp jepp klock ich persönlich gehe fest davon aus dass es gar nicht mehr so
lange dauern wird bis da was in der richtung rauskommt mein windows 11 selbst kam 2021 oder
so windows 11 release date ja ende 2021 also ich denke mal so 2025 oder so dann kann ich mir das
schon vorstellen ich würde windows 11 auch mögen wenn es endlich die möglichkeit gäbe die icons
hier unten zu entgruppieren glücklicherweise gibt es die mit dem nächsten update sofern sie das nicht
auch rausschmeißen bei microsoft weiß man ja nie was haben wir sonst noch zu bieten software
entwicklung ist viel zu teuer ja softwareentwicklung ist zu teuer wenn man versucht
dinger zu machen die technisch nur schlecht zu lösen sind also wenn man sachen verkauft
bevor man guckt ob das überhaupt in die jeweilige software passt oder oder was softwareentwicklung
auch teuer macht ist wenn man seine entwickler so abfuckt mit irgendwas anderem dass sie alle
abhauen und man keine mehr hat die software entwickeln für einen oder wenn man versucht
besonders billig sachen irgendwie nach frag mich nicht indien auszusourcen und dann feststellt
da kommt da nichts raus bei der koste am ende doppelt aber gucken was der experte dazu sagt
alternativ kann man auch sap und oracle kaufen ja dann wird es auch teuer gibt es noch gibt es
so einen dritten im bunde der euch jetzt einfällt also mir fällt spontan wenn es um ultra nervige
lizenzen und uns dummes zeug geht immer sap und oracle ein was gibt es da sonst noch so ibm
ibm hatte ich in letzter zeit software mäßig wenig erfahrung ich kenne ibm noch aus der aus
der notes zeit salesforce aber so oft wie hier ibm genannt wird muss da was dran sein
okay dann lasst uns mal kurz gucken was der experte dazu sagt viel zu teuer diesen satz
softwareentwicklung ist viel zu teuer diesen satz hast du mit sicherheit in dem einen oder
anderen zusammenhang auch schon mal gehört warum habe ich das überhaupt auf so einem hohen auf so
hohen auflösung stehen also die gängigen wege zu hohen kosten entgegenwirken möchte dazu gehören
unter anderem das outsourcing der verzicht auf qualitätssichernde maßnahmen in den vergangenen
jahren mal gucken ob wir golo heute wieder als echsenmensch enttarnen können gespannt bisher war
das in jedem video der fall und auch gerne der einsatz von low code oder gar no code plattformen
und so weiter und trotzdem ändert sich nicht wirklich etwas ich habe nicht den eindruck dass
die entwicklung von software heute deutlich günstiger wäre als früher viel eher ich glaube
sogar dass die software also gerade in der gaming branche ist natürlich teurer geworden aber ich
glaube generell dass softwareentwicklung heute sogar noch ein bisschen teurer geworden ist also
in absoluten zahlen aber auch mit steigender feature dichte und komplexität die damit verbunden ist und
mobile plattform multiplattform hast du nicht gesehen würde sogar sagen dass es heute noch
anspruchsvoller und teurer als früher sogar das gegenteil der fall und da fragt man sich natürlich
schon woran das eigentlich liegt warum genau ist denn die softwareentwicklung so teuer und warum
laufen all die verschiedenen ansätze softwareentwicklung günstiger zu gestalten unter
ins leere wo ist denn eigentlich das problem und lässt sich software überhaupt günstiger entwickeln
oder müssen wir uns vielleicht einfach mit den hohen kosten abfinden das ist das thema für unser
heutiges video und in diesem sinne hallo und herzlich willkommen zu unserem neuen weekly
softwareentwicklung ist viel zu teuer das ist die gängige wahrnehmung und man braucht auch gar nicht
die wahrnehmung wohlgemerkt nicht unbedingt von den entwicklern selbst würde ich mal sagen sondern
wahrscheinlich von irgendwelchen überforderten management leuten die nicht genau wissen was
sie da eigentlich treiben das ist genauso wie diese aussage generell it ist viel zu teuer was
machen die eigentlich den ganzen tag so ja mit so einem management hast du schon komplett verloren
ich lange zu suchen um die ursache dafür herauszufinden interessant daran ist nur dass je
nachdem wen man fragt man durchaus ganz unterschiedliche antworten erhält da heißt es
dann zum beispiel sehr gerne dass entwicklerinnen und entwickler schlichtweg zu teuer sein dass
software zu entwickeln aber deutlich mehr ist als nur code zu schreiben dass es einen gravierenden
unterschied gibt zwischen entwicklern und programmierern dass an der softwareentwicklung
ja auch noch zig weitere disziplinen beteiligt sind ja jetzt jetzt sag aber bitte bitte nicht
weil wie wir alle wissen sind tests komplett auf der rated outdated sie betet einfach fehlerfrei
first try programmieren dann braucht man keine tests das haben wir schon oft genug bewiesen im
stream keine tests keine kommentare nichts keine dokumentation einfach first try fehlerfrei
programmieren und dann direkt live deployen und so weiter dann braucht man auch nicht mal irgendwie
geht oder sowas drunter weil es ist ja immer direkt fast richtig das wird dabei gerne schnell
ignoriert aber die lösung für dieses problem die scheint so schön einfach zu sein wir lagern die
entwicklung einfach in andere länder aus die ein niedrigeres lohnniveau haben und schon können wir
unsere entwicklerinnen und entwickler durch andere die zu einem viel günstigeren preis
arbeiten ersetzen und schon hat man sich gedacht mittlerweile mittlerweile geht der trend ja sogar
schon ein bisschen zurück und die letzten jahre geht der trend schon ein bisschen zurück so
dieses super super heavy outgesourced ist ja eigentlich schon wieder vorbei mittlerweile
gibt es aber einen weiteren trend man outsourced nicht total billig nach indien oder sonst wo wo
man gar keine nur müll bekommt oder fast nur müll bekommt heutzutage ist im trend man outsourced
und das nennt man dann near sourcing oder sowas und da geht man dann nach polen oder sowas und
lässt da die sachen entwickeln ich glaube ja das wird in ein paar jahren auch nicht groß anklang
gefunden haben kosten aber nicht das einzige problem auch die entwicklung an sich ist zu
teuer kekalu time ich habe es gesehen ich habe es gesehen habt ihr es auch gesehen
ex-mensch konform also der prozess sozusagen das entwickeln an sich und zwar völlig unabhängig
davon ob man nun hierzulande oder auf der anderen seite der welt entwickelt beziehungsweise
entwickeln lässt und dazu haben wir ja auch schon mal ein video in dem wir einen ziemlich häufig
diskutiert ich meine es ist klar er hat hier drüben er hatte drüben wahrscheinlich sein
vorschau bildschirm und guckt da ab und zu mal auf sein skript drauf haben nämlich günstigere
software durch weniger tests das geht häufig hand in hand mit der aussage tests würden vom
kunden ja ohnehin nicht bezahlt werden die würden nicht gesehen werden insofern seien die auch kein
feature und daher können sie auch einfach sparen richtig test overrated brauche ich
das bisschen testen das ginge ja auch problemlos von hand das könne ja nicht so schwer sein keine
test gerade erwähnte video übrigens noch nicht gesehen hast dann findest du den link dazu noch
mal hier oben in der infocard also langer rede kurzer sinn weniger geld für die entwicklung
ausgeben und unnötige qualitätssichernde maßnahmen streichen und schon wird das ganze wie gesagt
qualität ist immer 100 prozent wenn alles immer fast frei fehlerfrei funktioniert doch eigentlich
ganz klar ich verstehe nicht ich verstehe nicht warum da noch keiner irgendwie neues agile system
drumherum gebaut hat ich weiß wir hatten test driven development wir haben extrem programming
warum gibt es warum gibt es noch nicht als trend perfect programming oder sowas wo einfach immer
alles sofort richtig ist ich bin am eil und das ist die zukunft wir sollten mal unbedingt ein paar
zertifizierte zertifikate dafür anbieten und wenn das ganze noch kombiniert wird mit agilen
micro sprints dann ist ja so ich überlege euch mal das potential first try alles richtig durch
perfect programming mit micro sprints dann kannst du am tag acht sachen perfekt machen wo andere für
ganze monate brauchen wir sollten wir sollten unbedingt zertifizierung anbieten dafür zwei
stunden wie kommst du auf viertel stunde viertel stunde ist das höchste ist überhaupt nicht agil
genug ist überhaupt nicht agil genug zwei stunden sprints für viertel stunde mit gesprint und dann
wird zwei stunden retrospektive und planning gemacht nur dadurch ist man dann auch 15 minuten
produktiv sehr danke für den sub und und der trend geht eigentlich schon zum nano sprint hin
dass man nur noch fünf minuten überhaupt was arbeitet am tag aber dafür sehr agil auch das
ist aber noch nicht das ende der fahnenstange denn noch günstiger wäre es wenn wir einfach
gar keine entwicklerinnen und entwickler mehr bräuchten sondern wir lassen unsere manager die
sachen zusammen klicken wenn wir die einfach weg rationalisieren könnten und die fachabteilungen
zum beispiel dann statt das einfach selbst als nächstes als nächstes kommen quantums
quanten sprints dann und genau das versprechen all die zahlreichen low code beziehungsweise
die in den vergangenen auf den markt gekommen sind du musst nicht mehr programmieren können
um zu programmieren und wenn wir das noch kombinieren mit werkzeugen wie chat gpt oder
github copilot dann kann man eine menge geld sparen denn man braucht dann einfach niemanden
mehr die oder der ahnung hat vom thema softwareentwicklung also das heißt weniger geld
weniger qualität das schwebt vielleicht irgendwelchen managern so vorher kann ich
mir direkt vorstellen also zum beispiel dem unity chef schwebt sowas wahrscheinlich vor
mehr low code beziehungsweise mehr no code mehr ki das und das muss ihm auch
vorschweben weil seine programmierer rennen mir auch gerade scharenweise weg zauberformel wie
man software endlich der nächst entwickelte selbst unity mit no code plattform richtig
günstig entwickeln kann und was kann dabei schon schief gehen nun ja die realität zeigt dass all
diese heilsversprechen nicht so wirklich gut funktioniert haben es ist sogar so dass die
gesandt dass die genannten maßnahmen die ganze situation nicht nur nicht besser gemacht die
machen sie teurer also ehrlich gesagt ich bin auch der meinung low code no code plattform
machen das nur nur teurer im endeffekt ja spaß zu dir eventuell eventuell sage ich mal den ein
oder anderen entwickler dafür musst du die gesamte infrastruktur dafür bereitstellen und jemand haben
der sich darum kümmert dazu kommt dass es ja nicht so einfach ist jetzt nur weil man eine
no code plattform hat dass auf einmal der 0 8 15 ja keine sachbearbeitung stut einen guten gute logik
sich zusammen track und droppen kann und im endeffekt muss dann die no code plattform noch
customized werden dass der das auf die reihe kriegt und dafür brauchst du wieder programmierer
und und noch ein infrastruktur team was sich darum kümmert also wahrscheinlich ist es unterm
sogar noch teurer neue probleme mit sich gebracht haben die man vorher nicht hatte und die man
eigentlich auch nicht haben wollte man ist in gewissem sinne vom regen in die traufe gekommen
nur dass man jetzt eben dumm gelaufen noch mehr was als vorher abbekommt es stellt sich nämlich
rasch heraus dass outsourcing outsourcing nicht so einfach ist wie das gerne dargestellt wird und
je weiter entfernt das land ist in dass die entwicklung ausgelagert wird desto größer wird
nicht nur der unterschied in der zeitzone sondern auch der kulturelle aspekt und da merkt man dann
unter umständen sehr schnell das kulturelle unterschiede und unterschiedliche sichtweise
also wir haben wir haben bei uns auf wir haben bei uns auf der arbeit auch ein paar externe
dienstleister und gesorgte sachen aber das weiteste entfernte ist glaube ich spanien und
die spanier sind echt nett das ist das ist immer lustig mit den spaniern zu telefonieren die reden
englisch ich rede englisch keiner kann so richtig gut für komplett flüssige konversation und
dementsprechend geht es wunderbar ich mag die spanier ganz schön gravierenden einfluss auf
ein softwareprojekt haben können und nicht umsonst gibt es mehr als ein unternehmen was
dem outsourcing über kurz oder lang in den vergangenen jahren um etwas im chat geht was
haben wir hier tatsächlich hatte ich management für mal in einer beschreibung auch diverse
programmierung was diverse programmierung man programmiert unterschiedliche sachen ja gut oder
meinen die sowas wie diverse programming was auch immer man da drunter vorstellen soll so nach dem
motto besonders inklusive programming naja da hat sich einer wieder irgendein wort ausgedacht ich
meine programmierung also softwareentwickler stellen sind ja schon besonders divers heutzutage
ausgeschrieben meistens für männlich weiß deutsche wenn für was sonst steht mwd dahinter
und dann kann man durchaus auch mal diverse programming einführen da hat bestimmt wieder
einer irgendwas aufgeschnappt irgendwelche buzzwords und gemeint wir müssen es mal
ja ich weiß langsam langsam ist gut ich bringe den jedes mal rücken zugekehrt hat und was dann
mühsam versucht all das was vor ort schon einmal gegeben war wieder aufzubauen also
outsourcing scheint nicht die magische silberkugel zu sein nach der gesucht wurde das gleiche gilt
übrigens für sparmaßnahmen bei den qualitätssichernden aspekten natürlich wird software
auf den ersten blick kurzfristig gedacht erst mal günstiger wenn man auf das schreiben der
ganzen kurzfristig das ist ungefähr so wie bei unity wo was gerade davor hatten kurzfristig
um kurzfristig gute zahlen zu generieren ist das wahrscheinlich ganz gut langfristig für
den arsch und irgendwelche tester abzuziehen oder überhaupt keine richtigen tests mehr zu
machen oder sagen wir mal irgendwelche wir setzen leute davor und lassen es wirklich mal ausprobieren
tests und was es nicht alles gibt das recht sich halt über kurz oder lang tests verzichtet aber
das ist dann halt doch eine sehr kurzsichtige vorgehensweise denn könnte überraschung das
recht sich sehr schnell dann nämlich wenn zum beispiel fehler die schon mal behoben waren auf
einmal auf unerklärliche weise wieder auftauchen oder wenn fehler auf einmal vermehrt vom kunden
gefunden werden statt von der entwicklung und so weiter das ist beispielsweise in der gaming
branche vollkommen normal heutzutage wenn die games rauskommen man fragt sich heutzutage wirklich
ernsthaft wie konnten spiele damals auf plattformen existieren die man nicht day one patchen konnte
und dann merkt man dass man sich mit diesen spara maßnahmen ein bär unmöglich hat denn
langfristig geht das sparen an der qualität eigentlich immer nach hinten los ja sehe ich
genau so merken zu viele unternehmen eben erst dann wenn das kind schon in den brunnen das liegt
aber auch und jetzt muss ich mal was sagen das liegt aber auch daran dass ich dass die sich
irgendwelche komischen berater immer holen und von denen sich irgendwie was aufs ohr erzählen
lassen so die die die neuesten buzzword trends und dann denken das ist wenn das wenn das wenn
das fang macht dann machen wir das mit unserer kleinen zwölf mann klitsche auch so nach dem
studios testet auch automatisiert ganz ehrlich mich würde mich würde wundern wenn heute ein
halbwegs funktionierendes größeres software projekt nicht automatisiert testen würde natürlich ist die
frage wie umfangreich das ganze ist und was sie da alles drunter verstehen aber anders kannst du es
ja eigentlich kaum noch machen gerade überlegt überlegt euch mal gehen wir mal gehen wir mal
von spielen weg ja das wahrscheinlich auch gehen wir mal von spielen weg heute gibt es ja auch
teilweise sehr viel komplexität in software die es früher nicht gegeben hat allein schon dadurch
dass du heute android ios windows und mac supporten musst mit deiner anwendung vielleicht niemand
supportet linux leider aber nehmen wir das mal dabei plus eventuell noch web du brauchst dann
du musst dann quasi so eine so eine so die kernkomponenten musst du quasi releasen als in
irgendeiner art und weise was für web mobile und desktop und das dann noch für jeweils zwei
unterschiedliche plattform mehrere browser wurde es testen wenn du das heutzutage nicht automatisiert
zumindest einmal die grundlegenden sachen test ist dass das kann nur in die hose gehen naja und
über low code und über no code plattformen über die brauchen wir eigentlich auch nicht großreden
insbesondere das versprechen dass man keine entwicklerinnen und entwickler und dass fachabteilungen
jetzt einfach ihre eigene software bauen könnten das ist gelinde gesagt völliger humbug und das
haben inzwischen auch viele unternehmen gemerkt das ganze gipfelt dann in der absurdität dass
inzwischen zahlreiche unternehmen die auf derartige werkzeuge gesetzt haben inzwischen
ernsthaft stellen ausschreiben wo dann und diesen begriff muss man sich mal auf der zunge zergehen
lassen ein no code entwickler ja das ist wirklich absurd aber höchstwahrscheinlich ist damit das
gemeint was ich versucht habe am anfang schon zu beschreiben dass man dann einen entwickler
einstellt der die low code no code plattform soweit kaste meist dass der 08 15 fachbereich
du teilen auch seinen schritt zusammen klicken kann weil er es halt in der standard ausführung
nicht checkt oder kann man sich echt fragen so ja wie wäre es wenn ihr das gleich leute entwickeln
dass die ahnung davon haben ich glaube mehr muss man dazu eigentlich gar nicht sagen um zu zeigen
dass das marketing für solche plattformen zwar das kommt das will ich jetzt mal gucken lasst
uns mal gucken wie viele wie viele no code entwickler wir finden no code entwickler low
code suchen wenn man irgendwie gar nichts aber ich glaube die suche sagt einfach nur
low code low code developer ja aber das ist das was ich gesagt habe die sollen sich halt
eben ums kasten weißen der low code plattform kümmern und wie low code mobile apps sind haben
die sich glaube ich auch nicht überlegt gut weiter ja ich würde auch gerne einen job suchen
für nix wirklich guten job gemacht hat aber dass die realität der auf diesem weg geschürten
erwartungshaltung hat ich guten job gemacht um zu zeigen dass das marketing für solche plattformen
zwar ein vordergründig wirklich guten job gemacht hat aber dass die realität der auf diesem weg
geschürten erwartungshaltung hat einfach nicht mal ansatzweise gerecht wird und das gleiche gilt
auch für ki denn das ki zumindest derzeit allen erfolgen zum trotz ebenfalls nicht in der lage
ist entwicklerinnen und entwickler ernsthaft ansatzweise zu ersetzen auch darüber brauchen wir
eigentlich nicht mehr zu sprechen ja und das bleibt dann unter ehrlich zu sein nicht mehr so
übermäßig viel und die kosten in der softwareentwicklung die sind all diesen maßnahmen
zum trotz also trotz aussehen trotz sparmaßnahmen bei der qualität trotz low code trotz no code
und trotz ki irgendwie nicht so wirklich gesunken und da stellt sich dann halt schon die frage was
ist denn eigentlich die wirkliche ursache für die hohen entwicklungskosten ja so eine no code
microcontroller firmwareentwickler wäre auch mal was ja oder so eine no code kernel treiber
entwickler ich glaube sollten wir sollten wir mal ausschreiben weil all die genannten dinge scheinen
es ja nicht zu sein könnte es vielleicht eventuell sein dass man mit all diesen dingen die ganze
zeit an der falschen stillschraube gedreht hat und ich glaube die antwort auf diese frage die
lautet ganz klar ja denn die ursache für hohe kosten in der softwareentwicklung die liegt ganz
woanders und die ist vor allem viel tiefgreifender okay ich sage man da nichts ändert solange man
die ursachen nicht angeht wird sich auch an den hohen kosten nichts ändern und alles andere ist
und bleibt halt nur symptomkur okay aber was ist denn nun die ursache oder besser gesagt was sind
denn nun die ursachen für die hohen kosten und tatsächlich gibt es eine ganze bandbreite von
antworten aber die erste und meiner meinung nach mit abstand wichtigste ist dass viel also
ich bin mir nicht so ganz sicher wie das jetzt mit dem video zusammenhängt aber ich ich halte
diese aussage auch für ziemlichen management bullshit ich kann ja auch sagen warum chat
wie lange brauchen laut management logik zwei frauen um ein kind zu bekommen wie viel monate
eine frau braucht neun monate wie lange brauchen zwei frauen ich meine wie wir alle wissen 4,5
monate nur noch da sieht man dass diese sachen mit prozentualer planung und dieses ja dann machst du
30 prozent projekt a 25 projekt b dann a jetzt sind die 15 prozent weggefallen die können wir
5 prozent fortschritt hier dass das mit der praxis eigentlich oder mit der realität meistens nicht
so viel zu tun hat das ziel nicht klar ist was überhaupt entwickelt ja die synergie effekte
sollte man nicht unterschätzen vielleicht vielleicht sind die sogar schneller fertig
als zusammen mit neun ja wie so viel wie so hinter vergleich so wird bei projekten doch
oftmals gerechnet so nach dem motto ok wir haben das wird projekt wird geplant auf so und so viel
personen tage das heißt wir ja stecken da jetzt mal so und so viele leute hin und natürlich ist
jeder prozent da ist dann macht es auch keinerlei unterschied ob man jetzt da 10 oder 20 mit 20
geht es dann doppelt so schnell also ich will nicht sagen dass es nie und gar nicht beachtet
wird wie so immer ist es ja zehn prozent manager beherrschen ihren job auch genau wie in allen
anderen bereichen aber es wird halt auch verkackt und dass das ziel oftmals nicht klar ist das hat
er glaube ich auch gerade gesagt dem würde ich auch zustimmen viel interessanter ist die frage
wie lange dauert der film wenn keiner zuschaut oder ist der mond da wenn niemand hinschaut
also fragen um frau über fragen werden soll und eine ganze bandbreite von antworten aber die erste
und meiner meinung nach mit abstand wichtigste ist dass viel zu oft das ziel nicht klar ist
ja was überhaupt richtig werden ja und dass dann da sprechen es auch nur mangelhaft geplant werden
da würde ich ihm komplett recht geben und dass manchmal ganz gerne auch was viel geileres
verkauft wird als es eigentlich ist denn wenn ich nicht weiß wo ich am ende überhaupt hin möchte
dann wird es sehr schwer den optimalen weg dahin zu finden und wenn ich dann während ich schon
unterwegs bin das ziel noch zig mal überarbeite und ändere dann ist klar dass ich unter umständen
sehr sehr lange zeit in eine sehr falsche richtung laufen werde und das wird dann logischerweise auch
entsprechend sehr teuer das heißt das erste woran man mal etwas machen müsste wäre die eigentliche
vision zu schärfen das zielbild klarer zu definieren und sich bevor man losläuft zu
überlegen wo man überhaupt hin möchte und wie man dahin kommt oder die vision zu schärfen ist
aber auch schon ganz schöner management talk gewesen jetzt falls man das tatsächlich nicht
definieren kann dann sollte man wenigstens aufhören so zu tun als ob man ein klares ziel vor augen
hätte und dann sollte man vor allem auch aufhören zu behaupten der umfang der zeitliche
rahmen und die erwarteten kosten die stünden schon fest ich würde ich würde sagen leute das ist schon
unser key zum success oder wir müssen nur den scope richtig definieren damit wir das nächste level
erreichen und wie der chat gesagt hat synergie effekte nutzen aber selbst wenn das alles als
voraussetzung gegeben ist dann hilft das alleine noch nicht denn es muss auch entsprechend
kommuniziert werden eine detailliert ausgearbeitete vision und das ausgefeilteste konzept das nützt
genau gar nichts wenn mein entwicklungsteam nicht versteht wohin die reise fachlich das stimmt das
ist aber auch ein bisschen das liegt als zumindest so wie ich es in der alten firma bei mir mit
gekriegt habe so ein bisschen das problem war aber auch zumindest bei meinem letzten arbeitgeber
dass das das unterste management die unterste management ebene die haben einfach extrem
gefällt oftmals nicht jeder aber oftmals haben die extrem gefällt dabei das was gewollt ist
ordentlich rüberzubringen an die leute die es machen müssen und umgedreht wo fast noch mehr
gefällt wurde ist mit dem was passiert ist in der umsetzung oder wie die umsetzung läuft das
halbwegs ehrlich und realitäts nah nach oben zu kommunizieren also die sachen sind ja oftmals ich
würde sagen der verlust von oben nach unten war vielleicht das noch sagen wir mal 80 prozent von
der vision sind angekommen bei den leuten die es machen mussten ok aber umgedreht was bei der
umsetzung so alles gewesen ist wie es da wie es da läuft wie der status ist da sind ungefähr von
sagen wir mal von der realität vielleicht noch 40 prozent oben angekommen und dementsprechend hat man
auch zunehmend gesehen dass die entscheidungen zunehmend und das war ein großes problem bei
meinem alten arbeitgeber die entscheidungen hatten mit fortschreitender projektdauer immer
weniger realitätsbezug zu den eigentlichen problemen und arbeiten im projekt das war ein
riesengroßes problem und da es sind auch schon einige sachen richtig krass gegen die wand gefahren
natürlich wurden die nie verkauft als gegen die wand gefahren sondern man hat das man hat den
scope umdefiniert oder sowas zum beispiel eines meiner schönen meiner besten beispiele dafür von
meinem alten arbeitgeber was man gemacht hat und zwar ist ich habe bei der bank gearbeitet und die
haben sich überlegt die hat natürlich auch ein paar außendienstmitarbeiter und sowas und die
haben sich überlegt wir könnten doch unseren außendienstmitarbeitern einen dsgv konformen
in anführungsstrichen cloud speicher zur verfügung stellen wo die beispielsweise ihre abgeschlossenen
verträge oder irgendwelche anderen ja so kritische sachen speichern können von der idee her muss man
sagen nicht schlecht oder und das ist auch schon ein paar jahre her da haben die meisten leute
lieber ihre sachen noch auf dropbox gezogen anstatt dass die sgv das war doch teilweise sogar noch
dsgv also müsst ihr sagen die idee ist ja gar nicht verkehrt so das problem ist nur wisst ihr wie das
projekt umgesetzt wurde irgendjemand hat gesagt wir also die vision war wir wollen quasi unseren
außendienstmitarbeitern für so geschäfts für sogar wie weiß ich wie man das genau nennt für
also dsgv relevante inhalte einen cloud storage speicher bieten so das problem dabei war nur dass
sie gar kein cloud storage speicher haben wollten die wollten einen speicher haben der für den
außendienstmitarbeiter so aussieht wie einen dropbox klon eben cloud speicher was die nicht
wollten ist dass das im back end zwangsläufig als cloud speicher implementiert sein muss die
wollten einfach im front end was was ein bisschen aussieht wie dropbox heißt nicht dass man wirklich
cloud technologie verwenden musste mit wir haben zwölf standorte europaweit verteilt und darüber
kassandra db mit unten drunter irgendeinem cluster file system und einem klar das war
überhaupt nicht notwendig so und was hat man gemacht man hat am ende eine lösung gebaut auf
ich sage jetzt die software nicht auf der es basiert aber man hat es vielleicht früher schon
ein paar mal gehört mittlerweile ist nicht mehr so angesagt man hat eine software lösung gebaut die
auf so eine art im prinzip hätten die im prinzip hätten die sich ein bisschen storage kaufen müssen
und und eventuell ein bisschen s3 davor machen müssen dass das ich glaube du kannst sogar
mittlerweile easy s3 auf jedem x beliebigen linux server machen also das wäre alles wäre letztendlich
wäre das alles gewesen ja man hätte man hätte zwei drei linux kisten hinstellen müssen an ordentliche
storage angebunden was repliziert ist zwischen zwei rechenzentren und davor hat man vielleicht
s3 irgendein s3 schnittstelle gesetzt fertig aus das wäre wahrscheinlich alles gewesen was man
gebraucht hätte allerdings wie das dann wieder so ist wurden die sachen nicht richtig kommuniziert
nach oben und nach unten und am ende wurde eine lösung gebaut die auf so eine art ja distributed
file system aufgesetzt hat nur mit dem unterschied dass wir es halt überhaupt nicht so verwendet
haben also stellen euch vor man benutzt ein distributed file system um einem um um außendienst
leuten einen cloud speicher anzubieten es ist vollkommen egal der endpunkt den die leute
benutzen ist immer der gleiche also es ist überhaupt die sehen das überhaupt nicht okay
aber jetzt überlegt euch mal ihr benutzt ein ein größeres cluster file system oder es war
kein cluster file system eine distributed storage technologie aber ihr habt nur zwei
rechenzentren die dafür benutzt werden was ist denn das erste problem was ihr habt oder so eines
der ersten probleme an die ihr denken könnt ach ja ich sage euch an ich sage euch an der an der
stelle auch natürlich müsst ihr euch auch noch überleben ist blitz ja das ist in der tat ein
problem natürlich müsst ihr euch auch noch überlegen wie viel replizierung einzelner dateien
ihr haben wollt so und jetzt kann ich jetzt lange rede kurzer sinn jetzt sage ich euch mal das
problem wenn man cloud technologien für für nicht cloud anwendungen benutzt obwohl man sie gerne so
nennen möchte dann baut man einen distributed storage cluster auf aus sagen wir mal zehn notes
pro standort und du sagst okay wir machen sagen wir machen zwei replikas oder wir machen drei
replikas pro datei wie stellst du denn jetzt sicher bei zehn notes pro zwei standorten dass
nicht alle drei replikas an dem standort laufen der vielleicht ausfällt schon mal schon mal
nachgedacht darüber die chance ist gar nicht so unwahrscheinlich dass von 20 notes die drei
dateien genau dort liegen die in dem standort der gerade ausfällt also wenn ihr zwei rechenzentren
habt jeweils zehn notes und jede datei also insgesamt 20 notes und jede datei wird dreimal
repliziert das heißt nicht zwangsläufig dass die datei mindestens einmal vorhanden ist an dem
standort der nicht ausfällt und dann macht man eine sache und dann mal storage kopiert das wäre
easy wenn du irgendwie ein replizierendes storage system drunter hättest aber nein man hat es ja
mit einem absichtlich mit einem distributed cloud storage system machen wollen was was im prinzip
dafür ausgelegt ist eigentlich dafür ausgelegt ist man hat 30 standorte in europa und an jedem
standort laufen 1 2 notes so dafür ist es ausgelegt aber nein man benutzt es so man hat
zwei standorte und man hat an jedem standort zehn notes und wisst ihr worauf das ganze dann
rausgelaufen ist am ende man hat die replikas hochgestellt auf elf auf elf und warum auf elf
wer kommt drauf warum auf elf post schimpf schätze feinfeld warning richtig na wenigstens
okay paar haben aufgepasst genau weil man zehn notes pro standort hatte dass immer mindestens
einmal das sicher im anderen standort ist und ihr könnt euch nicht vorstellen was das für storage
gefressen hat das hatte mega performance probleme am ende das hatte mega probleme wenn
mal irgendwas neu hinzugefügt werden musste an notes und das hatte ultra viel übertragung zeug
zwischen den rechenzentren und das hat nur probleme gemacht das ist ein ein das ist ein
projekt wo man sieht was passiert wenn das management auf den ebenen zwischen denen die
sich die visionen ausdenken und die dies umsetzen müssen komplett versagt das war hardware mäßig
enorm teuer das war storage mäßig brutal teuer das war traffic mäßig mega teuer und am ende hat
es auch nur sehr bescheiden funktioniert weil man einfach eine lösung benutzt hat für etwas was
dafür überhaupt wofür sie überhaupt nicht gemacht ist und einzig und allein dessen weil die projekt
leiter sich in die hose geschissen haben nach oben zu kommunizieren damals wir brauchen keine
cloud lösung um einen dropbox klon anbieten zu können irgendjemand hat gesagt wir brauchen eine
cloud lösung wie dropbox das hat jemand gesagt er von der technik keine ahnung hat das ist
vollkommen vollkommen okay dass er das gesagt hat aber projektleitung und management haben
sich in die hose geschissen das war damals echt so die haben sich einfach ums verrecken nicht
getraut zu sagen wir brauchen keine cloud technologie um einen dropbox klon für unsere
außenleute bereitstellen zu können das einfachste wäre tatsächlich gewesen wir wir wir upgraden
unser storage stellen vielleicht ein paar linux kisten hin machen vielleicht wenn man super
vielleicht wenn man sagen möchte okay wir sind super cloud native wir machen es drei davor vor
der storage und fertig das wäre es gewesen es war teuer hat nicht richtig funktioniert genau das ist
eigentlich auch mal was wo ich ein video drüber machen könnte so sieht es aus das passiert wenn
die sachen nicht richtig klar sind dann software entwickeln die ein fachliches problem zielgerichtet
adäquat und effizient löst wenn ich vorher das zugrunde liegende fachliche problem auch wirklich
verstanden habe und das scheitert oftmals an der interdisziplinären kommunikation da wird dann zwar
in einem team sehr viel miteinander geredet aber alle beteiligten reden wunderbar vorbei
ohne das zu merken und wenn dann noch oder oder sie reden nicht aneinander vorbei sie erzählen
absichtlich blödsinn wie in dem projekt was ich euch eben erzählt habe die hatten zu viel schiss
damals zu sagen wir brauchen keine cloud technologie um das umzusetzen was ihr wollt und dazu kam also
was heißt so viel schiss die haben sich halt negative auswirkungen auf ihre karriere von
versprochen was auch wieder mentalitätssache ist in dem unternehmen ja das war halt echt für
einen arsch über alte ambitionen hinzukommen wenn man sich und den anderen eventuell irgendwas
beweisen möchte dann gute nacht hinzu kommt außerdem noch dass das software entwicklung
nein wir müssen uns hier im chat ja nichts beweisen wir wissen ja dass wir alle messe
five five hat sind durch die ganzen prime subscriptions zonen heißt das heißt ein
kennzeichen das merkmal ist dass etwas neues entworfen und gestaltet wird und nicht etwas
bereits vorhandenes einfach nur am fließband reproduziert wird denn in der regel ist die
fachliche domäne neu oder die technologie ist neu oder beides und das steigert jeweils natürlich
die projektkomplexität und wenn dann von vornherein zu viel gewollt wird zu viele features zu großer
scope einfach zu viel dann fängt es eben an heikel zu werden das heißt sich zunächst mal auf ein
mvp zu besinnen auf das minimal viable product das ganze thema auf das wesentliche zu reduzieren
das gesamtproblem in kleinere und fein granularere einheiten zu zerlegen die sich jeweils für sich
genommen zügiger und einfacher lösen lassen das wäre extrem wichtig und gerade diese zerlegung
diese strukturierung findet aber allzu oft nicht statt weil man der meinung ist dass man mit nur
eine handvoll funktionen nicht auf den markt gehen können und dass ein monolith erst mal
ausreichend sei aus architektonischer sicht immerhin sei man ja nicht netflix und das ist richtig du
bist wahrscheinlich nicht netflix aber trotzdem ist es eine gute idee am anfang schon mal über
das ende nachgedacht zu haben einen plan zu haben wo man hin will und sich eine landkarte
zurechtzulegen die optionen aufzuzeigen und zu wissen was man wann umsetzen wird was wie
strukturiert werden sollte und was wie mit welchen anderen bausteinen ineinander greift aber das zu
diskutieren ich glaube es gibt wenig drei buchstaben abkürzungen die für so viele unterschiedlichen
sachen stehen wie mvp könnte auch der most valuable player werden allzu häufig völlig
unnötige technische diskussionen geführt ob man die geplante anwendung der nun besser in
notes oder in go schreiben soll und in ganz vielen fällen wird das schlicht und ergreifend egal sein
ja und entscheidend das stimmt mehr dass ich das zugrunde liegende fachliche problem verstanden
und dass ich vielleicht leute habe die sich mit der jeweiligen technologie auskennen es hat ja
keinen sinn jetzt auf das nächste hype ding zu springen wenn man gar keine leute hat die davon
ahnung haben so nach dem motto wir wir machen das jetzt neu in rust niemand hat plan von rust
und wahrscheinlich war es auch die komplett falsche sprache dafür das war mit russ ist gar
nicht so gar nicht so ein extremes beispiel die meisten business kommen sicherlich noch nicht auf
die idee sachen in rust jetzt jetzt zum aktuellen zeitpunkt zu programmieren aber ein schönes
beispiel dafür war mongolien und note sql note sql note js damals vor ein paar jahren da wurden
so viele neue projekte gestartet und am anfang hat man sich überlegt wir machen das mit mit
gs und mongo db ja aber warum weil neue sql hype und und note js event loop beste und
äußeren und ohne sinn und verstand hat man es einfach gemacht keine ahnung davon gehabt aber
best ever ja der blitz ein lustiges video gesehen ich glaube nicht dass ich das jetzt finde wo es
darum ging so 22 programmierer starten ein projekt und am anfang diskutieren sie was super
komplexes und dann sagen so ja jetzt sind wir uns einig wie es geht und dann sieht man sie
noch die letzte letzte minute am editor sitzen und bei der ersten variablen benahmung connection
string geht die welt unter weil sie sich nicht einigen könnten darauf einigen können ob das
jetzt connection string heißt weil technisch korrekt gesagt connect das ja nicht und zwar
ich ziemlich realitätsnah und eine vernünftige und tragfähige struktur geschaffen habe außerdem
braucht man natürlich auch noch die richtigen werkzeuge und eine passende infrastruktur die
die entwicklung jeweils in die richtige richtung treiben und entsprechend unterstützen es ist zum
beispiel nicht sonderlich sinnvoll zukünftig auf einer service basierten und containerisierten
architektur aufbauen zu wollen wenn man nicht zugleich auch die passenden unterbau bereitstellen
kann ähnliches gilt auch für die anbindung und die integration mit legacy und drittsystemen
auch hier werden oftmals man braucht einfach für alles vertikale diago verticale skalierung und
micro sprints und wer nicht weiß dass er das braucht sollte ich bei mir gefälligst eine
beratung dafür einkaufen von der entwicklung wunder erwartet die sie aber gar nicht zu leisten
im stande sind und wo die entwicklerinnen entwickler vor allem auch keinerlei einfluss
auf den status quo haben sondern sich mit irgendwelchen seltsamen und merkwürdigen
konstrukten herumschlagen müssen ich finde ich finde wir sollten wir sollten auch unternehmensberater
werden ich meine 5 5 hat genug wäre der chat die chat antworten sind in der regel besser schon
besser als chat gpt wenn es danach geht hat der chat gpt nie entwickelt müssen und entwickelt
werden müssen der chat ist einfach superior ich finde wir sollten auch die next das next
gen agile framework entwickeln mit diagonaler skalierung und micro nano quantum sprints
auch noch irgendeinen coolen namen das ganze ding eigentlich ist agile auch schon wieder
eigentlich ist agile doch auch schon wieder autos also wenn das wenn das bei banken und
versicherungen angekommen ist könnt ihr eigentlich darauf wetten dass es schon wieder out ist da
gibt es doch bestimmt viel coolere sachen mittlerweile was was kommt was kommt er nach
agile no age also wir müssen wir müssen dann ja wir müssen da einen neuen wieso steht oben bei
einem twitter text weil das ein top top secret twitter link ist den ihr nicht sehen dürft weil
es zum beispiel in der fremdsoftware keine vernünftige api gibt und interessanterweise
geht die existenz solcher software wo man aus entwicklungssicht eigentlich nur die hände
über dem kopf zusammenschlagen kann auf ähnliche gründe zurück nämlich dass irgendwann mal in
grauer vorzeit irgendjemand gedacht hat dass das eine ganz tolle idee wäre eine bestimmte dritt
software einzusetzen weil die zum beispiel gerade günstig zu haben war oder weil man deren ceo vom
golfplatz erkennt ähnliches und wie gesagt da werden von der entwicklung oft wunder erwartet
und das ganze dann aber weil jetzt schon ganz viel im argen liegt natürlich unter zeitdruck denn wie
wir alle wissen menschen unter zeitdruck denken schneller und liefern qualitativ hochwertige
arbeit ab natürlich nicht übrigens das passende video dazu auch das findest du hier oben in der
infocard und leider führt das in vielen fällen zu einer mangelhaften code struktur wo dann direkt
von anfang an technisch also ich meine wer hat es also ich habe meine besten ergebnisse auf der
arbeit auch immer abgeliefert wenn alle fünf minuten der chef reingekommen ist und gefragt
hat ob es einen neuen stand gibt dann war ich besonders kreativ immer wäre der nicht alle fünf
minuten reingekommen wäre wahrscheinlich nichts vorwärts gegangen ihr kennt ihr kennt das sicherlich
auch schon alle so hoch es ist kaputt woran liegt ja keine ahnung kannst du mir schon ungefähr sagen
wann es wieder gehen wird nein ich weiß nicht mal woran es liegt ja so über den daumen gepeilt
wirst du doch schon mal irgendwas sagen können ich habe eben erst mit mitbekommen dass es überhaupt
kaputt gegangen ist ja dann dann update mich aber auch mal ganz schnell wenn es was neues gibt ok
mache ich nach fünf minuten und gibt schon neue erkenntnisse oder am besten so hinter dir stehen
dass du es dass du es auf auf deinem kopf merkst dass der atmet so elastik das finde ich gut das
ist ein schönes das ist ein schönes wort für aber elastik ist auch schon ein bisschen bisschen
bisschen ausgelutscht aber elastik anstelle von agile finde ich schon mal gut da kann man kann
man schön zertifikate für verkaufen elastik synonyme was gibt es denn sonst so elastik
stretchy springy flexibel rubber rubber plastic bouncy bouncy development wobei ich stretchy auch
nicht schlecht finde das wort muss ein bisschen blöd klingen aber aber noch management speak
tauglich genug versatile versatile ist nice versatile finde ich gut fluid fluid versatile
fluid dass das ist das eine gute kombination aufd versatile fluid development leute ich glaube wir
sollten echt bald eigene zertifizierungskurse anbieten wie richtig schön diagonal horizontal
vertikal dreidimensional skaliert wird mit dem passenden hyperscaler nur ein anderes wort für
cloud anbieter ist die nicht aufgeräumt werden was langfristig zu viel funktionen und teuren
nacharbeiten führt und da schließt sich dann der kreis denn wenn man schon so startet dann
weiß man schon dass es ein problem gibt und welch bessere lösung könnte man sich vorstellen als
dann druck aufzubauen und unser scrum master ist der fluid master ausser aus dem in der fluid
expert hier zu bringen denn man brauche ich habe ich habe ich nicht aufgepasst dann weiß man schon
dass es ein problem gibt und welch bessere lösung könnte man sich vorstellen als dann druck aufzubauen
außer aus dem ins spiel zu bringen denn man braucht ja vermeintlich mehr leute damit das
schneller dann wird es immer besser umso mehr die nerven umso besser wird es erfahrungsgemäß die
qualitätssichernden maßnahmen zu streichen und so weiter und schon nimmt der ganze teufelskreis
ganz wunderbar seinen lauf ja was können wir aus all dem lernen wir können als allererstes mal
festhalten dass das problem gerade nicht ist dass softwareentwicklung zu teuer ist das stimmt so
einfach nicht software zu entwickeln das ist ein sehr komplexes und anspruchsvolles unterfangen und
solche dinge die sind nun mal teuer und das ist auch okay so was aber nicht okay ist ist sagt
das man im unity ceo nicht vernünftig zu machen sondern hin und her zu eiern fehler zu machen den
ganzen prozess vor die wand zu fahren alle hinweise und warnungen der entwicklerinnen
und entwickler bezüglich qualitätsbedenken in den wind zu schlagen und zu glauben man müsse nur
genug an der kostenschraube drehen und genug druck aufbauen und schon werde es günstig genug das ist
wahrscheinlich weil es warm ist angestrahlt zu werden von irgendwie zig ring lights bei 28 grad
im raum wird nämlich softwareentwicklung überhaupt erst teuer das heißt wenn sich jemand beschwert
dass softwareentwicklung zu teuer ist dann ist das problem sicherlich nicht die entwicklung an
sich sondern der ganze overhead und der ganze ballast den man in einer schlecht laufenden
softwareentwicklung so mit sich herum schleppt und wenn man den loswerden möchte oder wenn man
den loswerden würde weil man nicht versucht die kosten zu senken sondern den wert der
entwicklung zu maximieren dann würde das ganze auch auf einmal viel viel günstiger werden was
heißt das nun klingt gut er hat ich würde ihm da auch voll ganz recht geben auch wenn ich nicht
professionelle softwareentwickler bin in der praxis setzt also das rationale denken manchmal
ein bisschen aus software zu entwickeln man sich im klaren darüber sein sollte wo man denn überhaupt
hin möchte was das ziel ist was ja das ist prinzipiell verkehrt was das mvp ist wichtig
vor allem dass es alle mitbekommen haben welche features man in welcher iteration hinzufügen wird
man sollte eine landkarte haben einen plan eine architektur die das mvp ermöglicht vor allem
aber auch schon als tragfähiger unterbau mit blick auf die zukunft entwickelt wurde man sollte
wissen wann die diskussionen um technologien sinnvoll sind und wann nicht wann man nur eine
stellvertreter diskussion führt um nicht die eigentliche diskussion nämlich die diskussion
um die fachlichkeit führen zu müssen man sollte wissen wie wichtig ein stringenter prozess und
eine saubere und zuverlässige qualitätssicherung sind und man sollte wissen dass das alles nur
funktionieren kann wenn man im team eine hervorragend laufende interdisziplinäre
kommunikation das stimmt primär um die fach das stimmt und das paradox ist wer das alles
beherzigen das hört sich jetzt erst mal dass das stimmt dass alle das mitbekommen was sache ist
das ist enorm schwierig wer vorab investitionen in visionen architektur prozess qualität und
so weiter tätigt der wird zunächst höhere kosten und der kanal heißt aber mit den langfristig
niedrigeren gesamtkosten und vor allem mit einer ganz anderen geschwindigkeit und qualität da
stehen und das ist am ende die frage auf die alles hinausläuft was ist dir wichtiger der
kurzfristige erfolg der zulasten von morgen geht oder der langfristige nachhaltige erfolg für den
du heute aber zunächst einmal den steinigeren weg einschlagen das ist das ist deswegen habe
ich keinen bock auf management sachen ich will mir um sowas nie gedanken machen müssen eine alles
entscheidende frage wenn also wieder mal jemand zu dir kommt und dich mit dem satz nervt das
softwareentwicklung ja viel zu teuer sei dann kannst du sagen ja das stimmt hätte sie aber
nicht sein müssen wenn man am anfang bei der planung und beim fundament legen nicht den
einfachsten aller wege gewählt hätte und da würde mich interessieren wie siehst du das wie sind deine
erfahrungen mit diesen themen zeichnen sich die projekte an denen du beteiligt bist durch
nachhaltigkeit und langfristige planung mit entsprechender weise gut paar stories von der
letzten vom letzten job habe ich euch erzählt im verlauf des videos mal gucken wie es beim
aktuellen wird da weiß ich noch nicht so richtig einzuschätzen da sind auch nicht alle sachen
perfekt aber das wird sich erst in zukunft zeigen eisigt aus oder wird er auf sicht geflogen alles
auf zuruf gemacht ohne dass vorher eine vernünftige konzeption stattgefunden hätte schreibt mir deine
meinung und deine gedanken dazu gerne einmal unten in die kommentare und wenn du jetzt sagst ja
vieles von dem was in diesem video angesprochen wurde das kenne ich leider nur allzu gut und ich
würde daran gerne etwas ändern dann melde dich einfach mal bei uns du erreichst uns am einfachsten
per e-mail unter hello at the native web.io und vielleicht können wir dich beziehungsweise euch
ja dabei unterstützen das nächste projekt von vornherein in bessere bahnen zu lenken die
e-mail adresse die findest du natürlich auch wie immer unten in der video beschreibung unabhängig
davon wünsche ich dir noch einen wunderschönen sonntagabend morgen einen guten start in die
neue woche passt wie immer gut auf dich auf bleibt gesund und dann sehen wir uns im nächsten video
wieder in diesem sinne bis zum nächsten mal und astro 3.0 was ist neu programmieren mit mario
astro interessiert mich so gar nicht windows 10 ist ein problem warum weil der support ausläuft
habt ihr nicht auch irgendwo gelesen dass windows 10 die letzte version von windows sein wird das
liegt daran dass viele medien lieber unwahrheiten als clickbait veröffentlichen da haben wir es doch
jetzt schon das hatten wir doch vorhin als thema mehr anständig recherchieren und dann auch noch
zu stolz sind um ihre fehler zu korrigieren aber ausnahmsweise sind diesmal die bösen
ich habe das jetzt mal versucht zu imitieren aber hat nicht so gut geklappt nicht allein schuld
daran dass dieser unsinn in vielen unserer köpfe verankert war der spruch windows 10 wird das letzte
windows sein stammt tatsächlich von einem microsoft mitarbeiter welcher den satz im zuge
einer offiziellen microsoft konferenz für entwickler ausgesprochen hat das war noch im
jahr 2015 ein englischsprachiges medium ist darauf angesprochen und alle und ich meine wirklich alle
medien weltweit sind auf diesen zug dann warum ist die musik im hintergrund so laut dass er das
gesagt hat überhaupt war allerdings ein fehler es war nie so vorgesehen er hätte das wirklich
nie sagen sollen und der mitarbeiter selbst der das gesagt hat arbeitet gar nicht im windows team
bei microsoft okay das ist das ist okay so genau wusste ich nicht aber das ist das was ich vorher
umschrieben hat mit einer aus dem microsoft umfeld hat das gesagt ja er hat eigentlich gar nichts mit
windows zu tun sondern arbeitet mit anderen unternehmen und entwicklern zusammen um sie
zu beraten über microsofts cloud dienste hier hätten die medien die darüber berichtet haben
zumindest stutzig werden sollen quatsch warum geht darum eine geile überschrift zu machen
alle kommen sagt cloud typ von microsoft solche dinge über windows der hat doch gar nichts mit
dem system zu tun die meisten newsseiten wissen nicht mal dass es da über unterschiedliche
abteilungen für gibt großen vorwurf will ich den medien gar nicht machen die ohne auch nur
eine minute aus dem schreiben die alle voneinander abbericht verpasst haben wenn euch bei einer
apple konferenz zum beispiel mitarbeiter sagt ihr könnt euer iphone in der mikrowelle aufladen
dann wäre ich auch angepisst wenn man mir im apple store dann die garantie verweigert auf
mein explodiertes iphone da ist mir auch ziemlich egal welcher mitarbeiter das gesagt hat merkt
euch diese metaphor vielleicht für später die werden wir die musik so laut im hintergrund
und obwohl microsoft diese aussage von ihrem eigenen mitarbeiter sofort dementiert hat war
das nachfolgende statement nicht wirklich genug um die aussage vollständig zu revidieren okay
also eigentlich okay warum ist windows 10 jetzt ein problem konferenz zu windows 10 spiegeln die
art und weise wieder hatte in der geschichte und noch dazu wird windows 10 deutlich früher
eingestellt als es viele nutzer erwartet die folgen ja leider leider könnten schwerwiegender
sein als wir das ist der pc markt im jahr 2019 gewachs und war mich jetzt doch nicht so aber wir
müssen ein paar taps zu machen ja er schon wieder tap zu wie praktizierst du nicht perfekt programming
wo alles fast frei funktioniert das aber schwach ich dachte durch deine langjährigen subscriptions
hier bist du feinfeld genug dafür und vor allem wo sind die agilen mikro sprints so die die die
variablen fluiden mikro sprints triple a unit tests vergiss es ich laber unsinniges zeug ich
muss jetzt pennen morgen früh normal aufstehen ach so das ist nur dass du anderen zeigen kannst
dass es perfekt funktioniert ja das verstehe ich das ist dann flexing quasi flex driven programming
fdp flex driven programming best in class best best of breed tools ist auch sehr beliebt ich habe
gerade ausgedrungen ich gehe jetzt ins bett wir hören uns wahrscheinlich morgen bis dann macht gut